okay you're recording now
okay um yeah i just wanted to give you a
heads up there
uh representative we're live and
recording
so um good morning
it's uh 9 9 31. uh i
i noticed we have a couple of uh members
that still are to
log in but we we uh our clerk is
uh is in another committee meeting so
there needs to be a checklist written
for red for the public
as chair of division three of the house
finance committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04 has extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
providing public access to this meeting
by telephone
and with additional access possibilities
by video
or other electronic means we're using
zoom
video webinar for this remote meeting
all members of the committee and the
staff of the state
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen
to the meeting on zoom or phone
following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar
starting in house calendar eight and
proceeding from there
we are also public providing public
notice of the necessary information for
access
accessing this meeting that's in the
house calendar i just referenced
we will be providing a mechanism for the
public to alert
the public body during the meeting if
there are problems with
access we want to make sure we maintain
access so if we're not
email us at lba underscore
fiscal fiscal at
leg.state.new hampshire dot us
and if uh if we do find that the
public's having trouble accessing this
we will go ahead and adjourn and
reschedule
uh please note that if we take any votes
today and and i don't suspect we will
they will be done by roll call so
uh i see that uh our clerk
is still away so uh representative bean
uh will will you take the attendance and
let's have each member make sure we know
if there's anyone else in the room so we
comply with the right to know law
yes sir i will representative rogers
um i'm president this is katherine
rogers i am in concord
sorry i'm in my dining room in hanover
alone
representative walner i'm in
my home in concord new hampshire and i'm
um
i'm alone in the house representative
i'm here present and home alone in my
office
representative edwards i'm here in my
home office in auburn
i have people in the house but my office
door is shut
i'm representative bean i'm present and
uh my wife is here wandering around
she's gonna be leaving shortly
um representative wyler
representative weiler is at the
chairman's meeting with the speaker
he'll
he'll join us when he can
looks like we're all set thank you okay
so
before uh before we kick off this
morning i just want to
there's been a bunch of emails floating
around relative to
our plan for wednesday afternoon
and because it's a little atypical
i just wanted to also be able to
describe in
in real time what i what i think we're
doing
i think what we're doing is that we
wanted to make sure
that we were really being accessible
to the public and that we wanted to have
our committee members
reach out to individuals
who we think have a particular point of
view that we need to consider
in order to make our decisions relative
to the dhhs
and veterans home budgets so each member
was giving a given a 20-minute time
allotment there no requirement to use it
for example
representative weiler is not going to
have a guest
come in but we'll start at 1
30 on the afternoon of the 10th
with a 20-minute allotment per speaker
or speaker group
i think we could be done by three
o'clock and if we go a little long
we will go a little long it's an
aspirational goal representative
right so uh
we'll uh and then there was a
representative a question by
representative rogers today about
can they present powerpoints and and i
think
that it's important for us to learn so
if
a powerpoint will help us learn then
yeah they can use a powerpoint i would
just encourage them to
maintain their time discipline so that
we can
hear everyone in the time allotted so um
so we'll figure out how to get a
powerpoint up i think mr ripple can get
them
get them in a position to be able to
share
so the only thing that's outstanding
is if for each of you who have invited
somebody
would you please just get clarity before
the meeting
on which line numbers or which
account numbers they're really talking
about
so that when when they start we've
already
figured out what aspect of the budget
we're referring to
and that and that we've done our
homework to get our head ready to hear
what they have to say
so um if we could get them to specify
which aspect of the or which line items
of the budget they're referring to that
would be great
uh with that are there any questions
from the committee relative to what
we're doing
okay not seeing any um
mr ripple why don't you go ahead and get
us going for
today's agenda yep sure today you have
the division of medicaid services and
karen is here as usual
and uh the director henry lipman is here
as well
along with a few other people from the
department
you said that oh yeah i see henry now
okay great um
chair may i ask a question about
wednesday
yes so we have public health scheduled
to present on wednesday
is your plan to just have them present
in the morning and then if they need
longer that they would go
into next monday um they do have about
the 90 accounting units so it does take
some time
so what i thought we'd be able to do is
if we start at our normal time that's in
the house calendar
yeah and just from the way these
have been paced i thought we could wrap
up by 130.
okay and then from 130 on it's one we'd
have the
other speakers come in if if you don't
think
130 can work then you know
let's talk about it and i can slide our
guest speakers that's
really kind of the optional part of the
day and the flexible part of the day
we we need to hear from you all in the
public health group without
um you know causing you to go so fast
we're missing your points
okay all right great sorry karen the
other thing i would point out is that
you have part two of public health
scheduled from monday the 15th so if it
goes over on wednesday they can come
back
yes
very good okay great um i'm going to
turn it right over to henry and henry
are you good to
uh share your screen with your baby i am
i would ask if kevin though could uh
bring over athena gagnon
um the director of medicaid finance as
well oh
thank you yes sure
um thank you uh
members of the committee chairman
edwards i'm gonna share a screen with a
powerpoint to start if that's okay with
you
great so uh mr lipman i think
you've done this before if if uh during
the course of the
the hearing if one of the committee
member raises their hand to ask a
question
i'm i'm going to interrupt you and i'm
going to try to raise my hand to find a
graceful closure of your thoughts so
that we can ask a question
sure please expect that and thank you
so like to just uh share what we had
planned for an agenda which i think is
comports with what you were expecting uh
chairman edwards
um and uh that's okay i'll just launch
into it
that's all right we're all ready um
so just as a setting um division of
medicaid services this is where you'd
find
our department identifiers i think the
two key people in the presentation today
will be myself and athena gagnon the
medicaid finance director
we also have with us today the
administrator of our quality
program supporting medicaid patrick
mcgowan and
david weeders the director of
information systems for
the department um and they'll i'll work
them into the presentation at
appropriate times
that's all right so
i think one of the things you wanted us
to start out with is what is the
mission and vision of the division of
medicaid services
henry yes it's not moving we're just
still seeing the presentation
not the slides okay
yeah thank you for letting me know no
problem
if your screen sharing you just it
should just show
what you're what you're seeing yeah if i
had to guess
dave just went off camera so he's on his
okay
i'm actually remote today so i'm not
going to be able to go to his office oh
darn i thought that's why
beautiful background you have there
though dude
excellent choice in are you seeing
backgrounds slide
okay in athena
i i get the humor of your background by
the way just in case you're wondering if
anyone
gets it i think are you seeing it are
you seeing it now
yes okay thank you
um maybe it'll work better if i
work it this way as opposed to doing it
through the
actual screen presentation um so
i think where we were starting on the
mission
and vision of the department of medicaid
division of medicaid services
again in this division a large part of
what we do
is provide health insurance coverage to
a variety of populations
medicaid is largely a categorical
program
for example the individuals who are
elderly and poor
the aged the blind the disabled
and so forth we provide a managed care
program medicaid care management program
through three commercial mcos
and what we look to do is to run that
program
um effectively and efficiently and also
just because we're caring for so many in
new hampshire
um nearly one in seven at any one time
currently we want to make sure that
they're receiving quality services with
good customer service
and in addition to the managed care
program we're also
so um covered a couple points on this
slide where
we are a publicly funded program and
we'll get into
um what components the state pays for
um other funds pay for as well as the
federal government
today we um you know my first statistic
here is we
as of the end of january we're at 214
individuals and just
update those stats as of last
monday we're covering two hundred and
fifteen thousand
five hundred three people in total um
72 793 of those individuals
were through the granite advantage or
sometimes known as medicaid expandage
expansion and 142
760 in the standard program which
includes
covering the children and the increase
since the start of public health
emergency the week of march 16th we've
seen a total increase of 38 083
individuals
21 and a half percent increase the
granite advantage component which is
a component that's driven off of income
saw the largest increase 41.6
or 21 378. and the standard program
is up to 13.3 or 16 705 individuals
our division operates programs as well
as provides
the interface with the federal
government centers for medicare and
medicaid services
we provide support to other divisions
that you'll
you've heard from or we'll hear from
over the course of uh
your hearings and basically we're
the centers for medicaid medicare
services looks for a point of contact
and that's
me as the medicaid director but we're
basically i describe medicaid as a team
sport we
we support in um both on the technical
side
and on the federal claiming side these
divisions i won't read these all
here to you but there'll be all the
divisions that you meet with
offering a medicaid program is
technically an
elective for states all 50 states
participate um in the medicaid program
actually there are also territories of
the united states that i think there's
seven or eight
territories that also participate in
medicaid um
if you do participate as a state there
are certain
things that you have to do in terms of
offering i see you're asking a question
about this i i do i um as you go through
this
um i i i hope part of what you think
we're going to walk away with
is i would like to understand the extent
to which
medicaid is offered as a managed care
service and that we have so many
initiatives in
dhhs to build out a systems of care
model
i'd like to know uh the extent to which
the medicaid component of our health
system
is actually amenable to
being wrapped in a systems of care model
and that's kind of
uh i don't know if you're going to find
that in your slide deck
but but when you get to the right point
i'd really like to understand how those
concepts uh that your program and those
concepts fit together
so if i think if i could digress and
answer that question directly now
that's all right new hampshire has what
is described as a 1915
b waiver which is a
waiver that allows the state to as far
as
if you will acute care services like
hospitalization prescription drugs
your typical health insurance bundle is
nearly
all of our enrollment the 215
000 i was talking about are in managed
care we have what we call next day
enrollment so when someone gains
eligibility they
go right into a managed care or the mcos
and so um in terms of the
services that would represent health
insurance as you typically would think
about it
they're mostly nearly the entire
population is and those that
are not are usually in it only
temporarily
not in it temporarily excuse me there
are other waivers that
um you'll hear i think ltss is later on
today
which aspects of that are outside of the
managed care program
most notably things like the home and
community based waivers and
hopefully that gives you at least a
little bit of an introduction in terms
of
okay um
and so we'll be covering a little bit um
more about the different services that
are mandatory and optional
later on the presentation um also
the key thing in terms of how much does
the federal government
finance the sometimes we described as
the
fmap federal matching assistance
percentage and sometimes you'll hear it
with another acronym but basically it's
how does the federal government
participate and offering in it
and for new hampshire it's always at
least 50 percent and
we'll get into that a little bit more
later on as well
as part of the family's first coroner's
virus
response act the public health emergency
from a medicaid standpoint
offered states and i know of no state
that has
declined this if you maintain continuous
enrollment during the public health
emergency
that the state is eligible for enhanced
federal matching percentage on the
standard population
there's basically the the adults and
in that category it's 6.2 it's about
four and a half percent
in the what we call the children's group
or chip sometimes
and then for the the granite advantage
program which is the medicaid expansion
there is no enhancement because the
federal match is
already at 90
and this enhanced match goes through the
quarter ending
um which the public health emergency
ends and we talk about public health
emergency we're talking about
so i thought might be helpful to have
some comparisons
out there in terms of how does the
federal landscape look
like compared to new hampshire
and let me see if i can make this a
so just in terms of the percent of
population covered is sort of
the top federally
u.s wise 28 of the population
is low income and 21 of the population
is covered by
medicaid or the children's health
insurance program
in new hampshire we we don't have a
separate
children's health insurance program
sometimes known as chip it's all part of
our medicaid program
in new hampshire by contrast 16 of the
population
[Music]
is considered low income 14 are
in terms of new hampshire being an
expansion state the granite advantage
program
and these statistics go back to 2018-19
period
just before the public health emergency
the most
recent number would have been 51 000
comparatively in terms of the number of
people are covered
in the adult expansion group and there
are now uh 39 states that have adopted
and i have a slide later on
that will also give you a sense of
of those orange states here which ones
are moving towards
offering expansion i'd also note that
in the bill that was passed by the u.s
senate
there are incentives for those orange
states to
adopt expansion as well in terms of who
medicaid covers i just thought it was
kind of interesting that
in terms of adults aged 19 to 64.
nationally it's one in seven in new
hampshire it's one in ten
for children um it's two and five
um about sixty percent uh
in new hampshire it's uh one and three
um
a third excuse me two and fives forty
percent one in three
thirty three percent um in terms of
nursing home it's uh five and eight um
and a national level
about sixty percent and in new hampshire
it's about two-thirds 66 percent that
are covered
individuals with disability we cover one
in four nationally it's one in three
and in terms of the total
population of medicare
individuals who also have medicaid as
sort of a secondary
um nationally it's one in five in new
hampshire
it's one in eight down the bottom of
this chart
is in the eligibility
levels you'll see that new hampshire um
compared to the nation has eligibility
that's basically comparable
in every category except for children we
cover
a little bit greater number of children
but as a percent of the population that
are children we actually cover
cover less compared than nationally
moving to the next slide the top part of
this slide is just
you know where does the money get spent
and
while adults and children
[Music]
represent the largest part of the
population it's the elderly and disabled
which account for the greatest part of
the expenditures and
nationally it's uh 23 are elderly and
disabled
um and they account for 61 percent of
the expenditures
in new hampshire historically it spends
20 percent
a little even disabled in 59
of the expenditures and um
when it's all said and done um you know
new hampshire
spends about one in six dollars in the
health care system as is done
nationally and about one in two dollars
are going to support
long-term care services and there's a
chart on the right here that kind of
breaks it down but largely
new hampshire spending um follows i
think our demographics we have
more elderly and
disabled an older population and
but even with that it still tracks very
much the national
scene um we'll talk a little bit
um in the presentation about different
eligibility groups
this lodged is the one way of looking at
it in terms of
from a low income individuals with
disabilities and elderly individuals
and then the next slide is basically
where
expansion stands at the moment
there are now 39 states plus dc that
have
adopted medicaid expansion um
and there are two additional states
missouri and oklahoma that are in the
process of
i sort of uh touched on this chart um
this is
a week earlier than the updated numbers
i gave you but this is how
in the department level we've been
tracking um what's been going on since
the start of the public health emergency
and again i won't read off all these
statistics but
you can see here that the darker red
areas are where we're seeing the greater
percentage increases and on the right
hand side
is the percent change and the number of
so i noticed the bottom stat children's
with disabilities in-home care
is it because of covid uh
clients don't want us in their homes or
do we have fewer workers willing to go
into homes and therefore
were we were in decline in terms of the
numbers served
um i think it could be that um within
on the medicaid program people's
eligibility can change within different
um uh groupings it may be that they
moved to it
they may have aged out of one group and
went into another um it may be that they
fell into another area but it's if we're
talking
about 50 children and you can see that
in other categories our low-income
chip non-chip children that which is the
lion's share
went up over almost over
758 children and another
2 161 and low-income children
and it could be that um they either fell
into one of those groups or one of the
other disability groups that they aged
out of
can i ask a question to mr chairman oh
yeah thanks for saying something i
missed your hand uh
representative irv has a question could
you just clarify
the difference between low income and
medicaid chip
sure um if you remember one of the
earliest slides
there's um was a
showing where new hampshire compared to
the let me just go back to
that might make it easier to explain
if you remember looking at the um
children's eligibility level
here we're at 323 and um
nationally it's at 255. what this is
really representing
is that new hampshire adopted a number
of years back that
children who are 196 up to
i think it's 323 of poverty
um if you cover that 196 to 323 you get
an enhanced federal match
on those children and so that's what i
think
you're seeing there is that uh the the
chip population is that group of
children that get the enhanced match
because they're in a higher
income um category does that answer your
question
representative so it's an age thing it's
um it's not an age it's a
it's an income thing for children yes if
their family income is a little bit
higher
again um the federal government was
trying to provide states with an
incentive to cover more children
and certain states do and and new
hampshire is one of them
one of the other things i thought you
might find interesting um
is kind of how geographically the growth
and enrollment has transpired and
we've broken into three um groups here
the granite advantage
which is basically only an income based
uh people that are
100 less than 138 percent of the poverty
um animal and are typically childless
adults
you can see that the growth
you know followed i think if you kind of
look at it
it spread around the state kind of you
know the portsmouth
area the rockingham county and over in
grafton county and carroll county are
some of the higher spots but it's pretty
universally
important to a large group of
individuals to
uh have gained coverage through um
through this program i think a lot of
your um
your hospitality your restaurant um
individuals who may have lost their
insurance coverage or lost income became
eligible
and were able to be picked up um as i
mentioned earlier
it's over 21 000 individuals have
picked up coverage since the
mid-march time frame the standard
program
which is more categorically
uh driven you can see that the growth
rate there
hasn't been as high but again
if you look across the state there's you
know it tends to follow a somewhat
similar pattern as a
granted advantage as people um lose
income
and then the disabled population
again people aging into it a little bit
lower growth but also an important
um important aspect of being able to
provide coverage to those individuals
and again this has not been a
an economic hit that's just been
do you have another question there
representative earth
i do thank you mr gentleman so just to
clarify for my own
sake the grant advantage has expanded
medicaid medicaid expansion yes
and the standard income base is the
children's 9010 match
it would be it could be um anyone who is
in the categorical areas it could be
other than the blind and disabled um and
and elderly it's the other other groups
of standard coverage a lot of this could
be children
yep well where's the chip that the
medicaid chip piece falls
they would be in this they'd be in this
category as well okay so one of several
groups in that category
yep all right thank you are there any
you're free to continue okay so i know
um from sitting into
division three in the prior budget
and in this one that understanding not
just
the financial numbers but what's being
done to improve the program
is important so the next number of
slides are about what we're doing
and quality and um developing
the efficiency and effectiveness of the
program and
i'm going to invite patrick if you could
patrick mcgowan who is the administrator
of our medicaid
quality metrics if you could
come in and talk to a few of these
sure absolutely and uh thank you for the
opportunity
um so this slide here um
highlights uh sort of the core goals of
our medicaid
quality strategy which is required by
the centers for medicaid and medicare
services when you have managed care
these are sort of the high level six
goals that we have
first starting and i think we give a
link at some point that
will go to the full quality strategy
that you can read
but this was more for uh sort of the
highlights
um so the first one in upper left-hand
corner is to assure delivery of quality
and appropriateness of care
so this is the section where we do have
quality measures that look
and monitor our members getting
preventative care
or actual evidence-based treatment being
provided
uh was there a question representative
oh yes representative or you got your
hand up oh sorry
sure i'm just not used to talking so
much without somebody
chiming in so anyway so then
uh below that um we look at assure
access to quality care
so whereas before we looked at the
actual
the care that was being provided you
know well
child visits vaccinations sort of the
preventive care the next one looks at
are you actually able to access that
care
so for that we look at our managed care
organizations provider networks do they
allow
members to have the ability to travel
within a reasonable time to providers
offices and are there enough providers
in that managed care organization's
network of providers
that would allow them to have all the
services that a typical member could
need
we also look at utilization data
to look at trends as far as how members
are accessing services to monitor to see
if there was change at all
which could indicate uh
changes in service patterns might mean
that there there could be an issue with
members accessing care and then we also
do look at
uh member grievances which is a
sustained
um filed complaint to the managed care
organizations
we do look at appeals when services are
being denied if members or providers on
behalf of the member are reaching out to
file that the mco reconsider the action
those can all be indications of an
access to care
of members accessing care and then
finally we
also do have a member experience of care
surveys where we get
details back about how members have um
if they're getting the care that they
need really in the time that seems
reasonable to them
and a lot of these are all really any
industry standard
quality measures that we're using
below that we have a sure vendor
contract compliance we'll talk about an
external quality review organization
that we have in a few slides
but we do do a annual
audit of the mcos based
on their contract with the state and
particularly to see if they have
policies or procedures that are in place
in all areas of the contract
we also do have the ability to enforce
liquidated damages we have some internal
reports that we do calculate for the
medicaid director to see on a regular
basis
how those managed care organizations are
complying with the contract
then we move up to the upper right hand
box which is manage continuous
performance improvement
this gets more into the areas of okay we
see
rates that or quality measures where we
think should things should be better
what do we do about it
well we do have a quality withhold an
incentive program where we do withhold a
percentage of the mcos
what we call capitation rates and
we set goals in particular quality
measures and if the mcos can meet those
goals
then they can get back um what was
the uh revenue that was withhold held
from them
there's also a component of that where
they could get a bonus
we also asked the mcos to do alternative
payment models with providers to where
they're incentivizing providers to reach
certain quality targets
um we have a few other programs as well
including
our performance based auto assignment
program so mcos that score higher on
quality metrics
they can actually receive more members
that
didn't actively choose a plan when they
are determined eligible for medicaid and
they could be assigned to
that plan um and then we have just
general performance improvement projects
that we do
um target population health activities
is the next quality of the quality
strategy
and to those that's where we have
particular populations that are
priorities in new hampshire
particularly those with mental health
substance use
or misuse some of the special needs
members that henry's already talked
about particularly with children
foster care children um and then
uh also looking at disparities as well
and then the final gallon oh sir yeah i
wanted i'm sorry
uh i under a managed care model my
simple understanding is
that other than uh the
assuring vendor contract compliance
that the contract has the mco
doing most of the other five boxes and
so i'm just curious
where our value add is relative to
uh just adding layers of management
redundancy
can you actually if i could uh
representative
uh there are i think all the boxes that
are here are requirements of
the state in terms of overseeing if you
will it's contractors there
are pieces that uh the mcos
do of all of these areas but in terms of
um if you kind of think of it as uh sort
of the
clerk of the works in a construction
project making sure that the
construction's actually completed to
specifications
we're we have a small group of
individuals that
make sure that uh that all that happens
we also are involved in setting the
goals based on
reviewing um the data on the metrics to
make sure that
the areas where the mcos are focusing on
are ones that fit the
state's priorities um
hopefully that's a little bit helpful
and we can maybe as we jump into a few
other slides it might become a little
more apparent what
what we're doing and versus what we have
to
have independent third parties by
regulation do
as well so as you were talking i was
thinking
what kind of external benchmarks are
there to determine how large
staff the state should have to oversee
these contracts whether it's a
purely judgment or if there's some
benchmark that we're
looking at and considering uh well i can
wait to the resourcing part of this
though
sure um patrick are you ready for the
next slide
absolutely so
so here um this is one value add we do
provide for members
using a lot of our quality metrics we do
have a consumer guide
that members who have recently
determined eligible
or during an open enrollment period have
to pick a managed care organization
it's a two sheeter you're seeing uh on
this slide
one page but this link will bring you to
the actual guide
our vision was for members kind of like
when you're making a purchase
on amazon that you can see how the
health plans are rated in various
quality measures
and we tried to do a broad list of them
both children's measures overall
satisfaction with the health plan
well child visits to members how the
plans do for those
and then managing some chronic
conditions such as asthma
heart disease blood pressure all of
those i think are on the second page
we also compare the health plans to the
national medicaid average so there's
some benchmark that they're hanging on
to
these are all driven by quality measures
that
you may have heard the acronym hedis
before but they're an industry
standard the acronym is probably less
relevant than what it
actually stands for but it is sort of
the industry standard on how
health plans are evaluated both for
clinical
and uh ambulatory uh metrics
any questions about this patrick i just
add that for example on the top measure
that
that can change year between year the
prior year would have flipped in terms
of
um one plan being ahead of another we
have a third plan now
which they have to have a certain amount
of experience before you can
include them in this measure but um
patrick i just want to confirm is the
top line is their
their national uh uh evaluation not just
new hampshire correct
i know that is the new hampshire
evaluation okay
um we're ready uh go to another slide
if there's no questions yes
um here are them we just wanted to give
you a little flavor for some of the key
performance indicators of how we
evaluate the plans
so you'll see one two three four five
different metrics that we look at we do
have over 200 metrics that we're
evaluating
at different periodicities here you'll
see
the i think the dark blue
is the new hampshire medicaid managed
care rate that's the total program rate
and then the kind of more turquoise
color we're actually able to calculate
what
new hampshire commercial payers have
scored on the same rate
and then we also add the national
medicaid average for context
the licensing on that data prevents us
from actually
publicly sharing um the rates so that's
why you'll just see a bar
but no value above it so and then some
of the
measures you'll see well child visits
in the first 15 months of life breast
cancer
cancer screening controlling blood
pressure and then the last two are
measures
of receiving follow-up care after
emergency department visits for mental
illness or substance use
typically in most of our quality
measures we do tend to score
higher in new hampshire than the
national average
but it's nice to see the commercial
perspective to where you can start to
see how we fare against
other products in new hampshire or other
populations
i have a couple questions about this
slide
at what age does the program begin
breast cancer cancer screening
um off the top of my head i don't have
it i can get it for you though
okay and the reason i asked that is
because the literature was bouncing all
around for a while
on what the right age is for women to
begin uh regular mammograms and so i'm
just curious
um how how that settled down and if
we're
complying with it then the other one
that i'm curious about is um
i see the follow-up visit after
emergency room visits for mental illness
and then for substance abuse
and the substance abuse is obviously
substantially
lower does that imply that it's
harder to go do a follow-up for
i think the new hampshire data would
show that i mean this is a measure that
it's kind of ironic because new
hampshire scores better we're probably
about top in the nation
for this measure but it's still a rate
that we believe is unacceptable
um so comparatively is it easier
than mental health um i don't know henry
if you
can't speak to that but the data would
suggest the opposite that it's easier to
do a mental health follow
oh that's what i meant yeah yeah so
so then i guess i guess given that
that's just a clear
um observation from the data
what what do we need to do differently
to get that 27
at least twice as high so if i could
patrick i think that we
look at it from a number of different
angles i think patrick talked
earlier about um the
programs that we ask the mcos to
consider in terms of apms or
ways of developing value-based care
we've asked the mcos to develop
relationships to improve uh that
follow-up
with providers we've um they have
requirements in the contract to do
performance improvement
uh programs in addition to that
as well as in our uh withhold measures
um incentives we include it there so
we're trying to come at it from
um a number of different angles and as
patrick said well we may be doing
very well comparatively it to the to the
nation it's a number that
we obviously want to have much higher
particularly where new hampshire has
been one of the higher states affected
by
the sud crisis
we also do have some process measures as
well uh chairman edwards that um
as far as how when members are
discharged from the ed
uh the mco is required to make several
contact attempts for each of those
members
so we do track that as well um
so it certainly is not a measure that
doesn't have multiple quality
initiatives attached to it so
i think it's probably one of the areas
between mental health and
where we're spending a lot of time
trying to
come from all different angles to to
improve
the delivery of care and the breast
cancer
oh sorry just so you know my frustration
with that answer
is i'm i'm and i'm sorry
i may be just a little impatient today
but i'm just hearing
that we're going to require more
planning more documentation more
conversation at the staff level
but fundamentally we don't know exactly
who needs to do what to get that number
higher
no i don't think that that would be
accurate representative i think that
we have specific measures built into the
contract in terms of performance metrics
that require for example
um and we measure them in terms of the
mcos
are they in fact um making those
contacts have they at least made the
attempts
um and so i think one what i was trying
to say is that
rather than just looking at one place in
the contract where we can try to
improve uh this measure we're
looking at it from a variety of
different angles and trying to
raise that measure up and so i guess i
would say that it's
it's not redundant it's complementary
it's trying to
um weave together a series of aspects of
the contract
to improve that measure
thank you sir um and just add uh
representative
edwards um we did actually see an
increase in this measure from the prior
year of about six percent
so and which would i think complement
when we started to place a greater
focus on it certainly is not where it
needs to be well we are seeing the right
directionality that we're looking for
thank you um are you ready for the next
slide
yes are you okay with the move ahead um
oh yeah no i'll keep interrupting if i
have more questions
no please um and the breast cancer
screening
um just so you know for that that is
uh we're hedis uses percentage of women
so there's not a set age it's a it's a
range and then they choose the range
based on
other uh diagnostic characteristics of
the patient
i'm i i was expecting there to be an
age one age where breast screening
begins
at 50 i think is what patrick was yeah
50 to 74.
oh so we kind of stopped at age 74.
correct
okay that no i i know and then is that
uh
once every two years three years what's
what's the frequency once a woman gets
started
so it's following the us prevention task
receive a mammogram every two years
can you see the next slide yes
absolutely so um
we showed you sort of some of the key uh
key performance indicators that we do
look at
when we did the quality strategy
updated our quality strategy we did
you see we compare a lot against the
national average
where our desire is to kind of start
comparing
new hampshire against a higher bar new
england tends to be a healthier
so we've started to look at how does new
hampshire compare in our rates
not only against the national average
but against the 75th
percentile of medicaid uh
care plans in the state so in doing this
we
um got together a group internally
and found 10 measures where we were
actually below the 75th percentile and
those were going to be some of our focus
areas over the next three years
to raise up to the 75th percentile
and the where we look at those as we
look at those in areas of prevention and
treatment you'll see some of the
categories here some
we've talked about before adolescent
health women's health
adult mental health children's mental
health substance use disorder and uh
one measure as well of appropriate care
so
uh the link here goes to kind of that
report we'll kind of tell you a little
bit more in depth of the different
measures
but also how we've um
fared we have a after a year and a half
of doing this work
um henry do you want to jump to the
results of that so we're on topic it's
the slide and then we'll come back to
the external quality review organization
all right so what we have here is we've
given you sort of where new hampshire is
in the baseline which is the column nhcy
2018 and i see why we mean uh calendar
year
2018 goes different than
the state fiscal year and then after
publishing
um those 10 priority quality improvement
priority
areas we have um an update of calendar
year 2019
how we've done and then we have a color
coding here which will show you
a range particularly in calendar year
how those results are red meaning
still below the 75th percentile but also
below the 50th percentile as well
areas probably would need more focus
yellow being
that the performance was still below the
75th but we are larger we are higher
than the national average at this point
um the lighter green being that
we had improvement from the prior year
but we're still below the 75th
percentile
and then the darkest green meaning we've
sort of achieved that goal
so you see the majority of the
categories
there's ten of them we're showing you
five here um
have uh the light green where um
in the prior slide where uh we've
we're improving but not at the target
yet this
and then the next one shows that of
these
almost all of them are at the 75th
percentile with one
um being still below the 75th and the
50th
so that's a lot of information at once
um
kind of the color coding helps a lot so
if we could go back to the previous
slide
sure okay so i think the color code is
often a couple of these boxes if i if
i'm reading your key correctly
um but let's talk about um immunizations
uh two things is is the hpv
via a vaccine is is that settled science
now where
uh people think it's really a good idea
that's been out for about 20 years dude
are we are we confident that's a good
thing to be given kids
i think in terms of our measurement
we're following um the national
committee for equality
i'm not talking about measurement i'm
talking about whether the hpv
is good medicine are we convinced it's
good medicine
well i'm not a clinician um
representative edwards i think where we
do then the other question is
um on these immunizations the for
adolescents i
i thought the last time i looked at an
immunization schedule
it had i don't know 30
40 vaccines that were sort of
recommended
so what does it take to get a
a green in this area for a kid they have
to have
the most critical immunizations or the
whole panel
so we have two different um
populations for child and adolescent
immunizations
one is focused on the younger children
and that may be what i think
perhaps what you're referencing that has
a far higher volume of
immunizations when you get to
adolescence it's really i think
three or four um and the most
challenging of those is the hpv
um vaccination i think it's still
open for debate where the challenges are
i think part of it is that it's a two
series set
and adolescent well visits what you have
adolescents that you just aren't going
to the doctor as much
as you were with children in their
earlier years but if you can see
the difference between these two
adolescent vaccination measures the
first one
when you don't include the hvv the rates
are far higher than when you actually do
include the hpv
so that first row you see has a 78.2
percent compliance rate
but then we drop down to 33.1 once we
start evaluating
members who also had the full hpv set so
if you had to say i think to your point
i think it's the hpv where we're we're
struggling
all right thank you i don't see any
questions from anyone else
so i would just add here representative
what we try to do is
you know as patrick talked about we're
looking at several
up to several hundred different measures
but we wanted to
um where we were not at the 75th
percentile of performance we wanted to
identify
ten things to focus on for uh several
years to raise them up and
you know we wanted to show you that
while there are
certain areas where we've made that
there are other areas where you're so
into it we still have more work to do
and
again i think you know there are many
good things to say about
new hampshire's medicaid quality but
there are areas where we need to improve
and we're
we're highlighting some of the
priorities here for you
i like that it's a huge program and and
there's a saying something like if you
don't measure it you're not going to fix
it so
i'm glad that i'm glad you're doing this
and we you know we try to work with the
mcos to focus on this and all the
different
ways that the department is interacting
with the public on these areas we're
trying to
you know leverage focus on this
um so i think that's what we had for
quality and
like to now i think one part of the
slide deck we were asked to address were
sort of for
four areas where um we feel like we've
had some key accomplishments and i think
i'll start to drive again from here
um so i think in terms of things that
we're
sort of proud about from the division of
medicaid services
is uh over this past year certainly the
response to the public health emergency
uh the division of medicaid services has
played a key role in it
i talked about earlier during the public
health emergency if you
follow the maintenance of effort
requirements the state is eligible for
enhanced federal match
and you can see here for for state
fiscal year 20
that represented 22.8 million dollars
of additional funding and for state
fiscal year
21 i'm expecting that to be another 45
million i will stop here for a moment as
to just mention that
[Music]
the the length of the public health
emergency
and has seemed
to have some different perspectives on
how long that would last when we
prepare the agency budget as an instance
we thought it would end
a lot earlier than it is you know we
didn't have the spike
that we saw um you know from the
thanksgiving period through
early february and then even
into the governor's phase of the budget
it's since i think the
the top end of the spike that the
federal government has anticipated based
on the rollout of vaccine
and the variance that
there's an expectation that the public
health emergency might last
as long as the end of the year calendar
year
21 or maybe even longer and so as we
look at some of our numbers
as we move towards the the next phase of
the budget process there'll be some
updates to these numbers as we learn
more definitively how long things are
going to last in terms of the public
health emergency so i just
as we get into this later just i'll
repeat that i think again but
also at the beginning of the public
health emergency before provider relief
money became
available to to our medical community
we were concerned about the
sustainability of our safety net and we
renegotiated
the mco contract to not bring
not spend new money but money that was
already appropriate within the
capitation payments to
reallocate it to our safety net
providers because
utilization of services were down um
and so that was i think an important
early help to
[Music]
safety net providers at qhcs um
in another way we were able to help the
community mental health centers home
health agencies
all of our what i'll call more
subsistence agencies
in terms of the provider relief funds
that did come
in the federal government depended on
state medicaid programs to provide
information so they could figure out how
to design it and it was quite a bit of
work that our
mmis team put together to make sure that
the federal government had what they
needed to give new hampshire's fair
share of that allocation
um one of the big issues that we'll talk
about um
later on a little bit more is that while
we continue eligibility there'll be a
time when the
public health emergency ends and there
are issues in terms of
if you will flexibilities the state of
new hampshire was able to acquire
through waiver
as well as eligibility that we'll have
to work through all that
and um that's uh we've been
if you will standing up all the things
that the opportunities that made sense
for new hampshire
and at some point we'll need to also
unwind those things and so we've been
involved in standing up and planning for
the ultimate end um
am i interpreting that bullet correctly
to think that there may be some
providers that will be disenrolled
no this when we're talking about
provider enrollment here for example at
the very beginning of the
public health emergency if you remember
the there was an executive order around
telemedicine
and for example new hampshire depends a
lot on
say children's hospital um to
uh provide care for children for those
children in need but in terms of getting
them enrolled so they could
provide telemedicine services we were
able to
get some flexibility to be able to
enroll
if you will of the boston medical
community to be available
to provide telemedicine services if that
was needed
and so it allowed us to use if someone
was already enrolled in medicare
or in another state's medicaid program
we'd be able to accept that enrollment
that eligibility for enrollment
on a uh temporary basis during the
does that answer your question
representative that's really great
it it triggers a few others but let's
continue
um 1135
is a section of the social security act
that
deals with the waivers that typically
come into play
during a public health emergency and and
one that we
were able to help
some families there's been a real
shortage out there as you may have
followed the news
that um you know some of the people left
the workforce
in terms of uh for a variety of reasons
in terms of whether they be nurses or
or aids or what or lnas and
um family members who had to provide
care for
for children um in particular and adults
um that it was hard to get workforce
they
were concerned about bringing workforce
into their home
um what we've been able to do leverage
our existing 1135
waiver in personal care to allow us
where you can't get help is to
provide some compensation for families
to provide services that would otherwise
be delivered for example a family member
may be
involved in providing a service that
a home health agency may have been
providing earlier or
another agency that they just they can't
there's just no help
available and so this is providing
for a certain number of families some
temporary relief this
this flexibility will go away after the
public health emergency but one of the
things i think from a public policy
standpoint
is that um after the public health
emergency is over
that our workforce um whether it be
nursing homes or hospitals or
or home care there's been a reduction uh
due to
people leaving the workforce and also
the effect that
education programs um you know training
people
that that we've we've lost some
workforce here and we're
trying to work to see what flexibilities
in the long term we'll be able to maybe
bring to bear to
help deal with what i think is going to
be an upcoming uh
shortage that will be very difficult to
work for when meeting people's needs
so expand on that word flexibilities
what are you thinking
give me give me a couple of examples of
what flexibility do you think we might
need
so as an example today for
[Music]
private duty nursing that we provide for
someone who might get be
you know a severely disabled child at
home
that there just aren't nurses available
through agencies sometimes to do that
and in some states for example they
allow individual nurses who get enrolled
in the program to be able to provide
those services so it's basically
opening up what might be
available in terms of nursing coverage
that some people don't necessarily want
to work for an agency
and so we're looking at that option
we're also
looking at seeing if the federal
government
will work with us on um extending this
personal care
opportunity um and when i say um
this opportunity it's not just the
willy-nilly thing that the individual
has to go through a
criminal background check and and
training and be seen to be
um capable of of delivering that
personal care
but is there a way outside of the 1135
authority which ends the day of the
end of the public health emergency that
we can structure some things but
it's kind of looking at um you know
we have um as you can see sort of
in the area of telemedicine we've opened
up a lot more avenues for
for care to be delivered and you know
taking out some of the
the time to get to people i think we
need to look at how we can expand the
existing workforce's ability to
to meet our beneficiaries needs and i
think that
uh we're also looking at nurse
delegation under
under and that may require us to work
with the office of professional
licensure in terms of
you know can individuals who have
received trainings for example
um you know like trait care as an
example is that
something that would be able to be with
a certain uh
supervision and sign off be something
that someone could specialize in
as opposed to having to rely on a
certain level of licensure to do that
and so
these are types of things that we're
we're looking into
because we know that there's going to be
an increasing shortage that
there are people who you know are not
able to get all of the
the care that's assessed to be needed
and
and we're trying to figure out ways to
be creative to work around that
so i assume your internal procedure is
that when you come up with flexibility
ideas that require
you figure out if a new hampshire
statute needs to be modified and
in which case you work with mr williams
who then in turn works with the senator
house
hhs is that your normal process
yes and also with other um bodies
you know a good example of that is what
we will talk a little bit about
later is the in the medicaid schools
area in terms of trying to get
um last session just before the pandemic
kicked in was senate bill 684 which
[Music]
provided licensure for school
psychologists so that they could build
medicaid
and also masters prepared people brought
them under the
so we do have to work with john as well
as other agencies
and the legislature of course as well
yeah
so in this budget do you have any uh
requests for funding to help with any of
these manpower flexibility
pilot projects or or if you had
a pilot project you wanted to try um
and you needed money where would you get
it
um i guess in terms of um if care is not
being delivered that
is been assessed as being needed that
that would create
some flexibility for us to um
be creative where we wouldn't need new
money to do something like that for
example if
private duty nursing shortage
[Music]
it would just basically moving from one
bucket to another some of the other
things that would require
legislative changes i think would
probably be things that we'd have to
thank you we also
took advantage of the federal government
provides states and the ability to
create a new
eligibility group um to do covid testing
the space basically provided 100
federal match and
you know early on in the pandemic in
terms of increasing our testing level so
we had some sense of
[Music]
what what the incidence of the disease
was in the state
that this was helpful to that today we
have just under 7
000 individuals who are in this
testing group this testing group would
end at the end of the public health
emergency
and there is federal legislation that
may
extend this for a longer period of time
we'll see
what comes out of the latest legislation
when it goes through the
this basically provided for testing and
some limited
diagnostics around it to ascertain
and then we were also involved in the
execution of
the expanded telehealth from a medicaid
perspective in terms of getting
the executive order um implemented as
well as
working on the rules uh as they affect
medicaid with respect to legislation
that was passed
last session on telehealth who is the
lead
person in dhhs who's the most
knowledgeable about
dhh efforts to support telehealth
so um dr ballad who's our medical
director is
um and uh jane hipps who heads our
medical unit of the two
individuals that are involved um
at a legislative level on the committees
that are
working on the telehealth rule i think
dr ballard certainly
um from the physician perspective um
in terms of how it can be used um and uh
jane from
um basically the licensure and medicaid
rules
could you show me their contact
very good so
um one of the things that the department
does is implement
legislative policy and federal
regulations and state regulations i've
talked
about the top bullet here which is the
medicaid to schools
program which school psychologists was
one of the
most important things but there were
other aspects of that
legislation that helped speech uh speech
therapy
that helped administration medication in
schools
we've also worked um you know
in hb4 in 2019 and adult dental benefit
design was uh passed and then
there's been a legislation there's two
bills actively
being considered right now in terms of
financing an adult
dental benefit we work with a
stakeholder group
and actuaries to to help shape and
design that
so so i want to stop and talk about this
a little bit more because
you you came in and you gave us a
special review of the dental program
and i got to tell you i forgot some of
the key stuff but
um i have an email from the governor's
office
who who it makes it sound
like there is no dental care program
in medicaid in this budget at all
and that he cited that uh
that we that the governor vetoed hb 250
in 2020 which which would have
established the program
and so i what i'm confused about
is is there a legal authorized program
or not it's a yes or no
yes and um
what's the source of the authority so
hb4
hb4 in 2019 the issue is is that while
there's a benefit there's not
adequate funding to to to to do so and
really
uh 250 last year and the two bills
this year really about um you know
providing both the funding
and the benefit design that would be
more economical to implement i think the
governor vetoed
at 250 based on cost and the
the two bills have a more economical uh
approach to them than what was in 250
last year
there's also to my understanding in the
senate
a timing issue that's being looked at in
terms of
trying to minimize um
the cost in this upcoming biennium and
to
but to start the program and i i do i do
know that
uh you know in the governor's
inaugural address he talked about this
as being an area that there might be
an opportunity to um
work with the legislature on i you know
from a standpoint of
of uh need the need is there i think you
know ultimately whether it goes forward
or not is a decision
of the legislature and the governor but
we've we have a requirement under hb4 to
be
so i'm thinking about what you just said
so it sounds like
there are two bills currently uh before
the legislature
to take the authority of hb4
and to shape it a little further and to
fund it
is that is that accurate i think that's
a
fair overall assessment of it um there
may be other people like john williams
who
could give you a more technical
explanation but i think that's a fair
characterization of it
okay so that would be another one of my
questions could you tell me
the two bill numbers so i can go look at
them and figure out
where it is in the committee process
please senate bill
um 150 which passed the commit
the health and human services committee
um unanimously
and my understanding is that there's
that's the bill that is
considered a date further out i think
january of
22 beginning um which would change the
date that was in hb4 right
um and then there's uh house bill
i believe it's 103. um both those bills
are in hearings uh this week to my
understanding i also have dr finney if
you want to get into this a little bit
further who's i believe
uh um out there who could be brought in
to give you a little bit more update
than i
just did right now if you'd like that
yeah that's that's sufficient i just
i just needed to be reminded of what i'd
forgotten and you did that
so thank you you also had sent something
to uh
kevin ripple i don't know kevin if uh if
that has been able to be distributed yet
i think it was just sent to you probably
the end of the week
just some notes from the meeting that we
did have
i think that exact document though on
our website hasn't been emailed out
although that information was contained
in a separate email i sent i had linked
to the
uh house bill 103 or the senate bill 150
fiscal note i'm not sure which so it
contained the same financial information
as in the document you emailed last week
good thank you um
so i think those two things give you uh
um the background that can be given i
think right now we're really
at the discretion of what the
legislature and the governor is willing
to
willing to do in this area i think it's
generally good health care to take care
of
people's mouths and uh and that it saves
money in the long run
the issue is what's the right size i
think
right
another area that has to do with sort of
federal compliance
um the federal government
uh asked the state to um
[Music]
document beyond what's in statute how
the intergovernmental transfers
that fund the county cap um and
to to put that into sort of a a written
agreement form
and we were able to um
complete a document um that
addressed the federal government's uh
cons
concerns to uh to put something into
writing beyond what's in our
state statutes we work with the
counties and coming up something that
in terms of state plan amendments
there was a lot of legislative activity
that came out of the last
session probably double the amount of
state plan amendments that we had to
execute on
and we had to do that at a time of both
a public health emergency
as well as losing one of our key staff
who uh works in this role and so i'm
proud of the
the team stepping up and making sure
that the work got done at a time
you know double the work with with a key
individual wasn't able to
to be there the whole time for us um we
also
um to i'm sorry see representative eric
has a question
oh yeah he does go ahead thank you
mr chairman can we get a copy of the
intercon governmental transfer agreement
you were referring to between the state
and the counties
and then the last two bullets on the
page are our policy that was
passed again a prior legislative session
implementing the medicaid for older
adults with disabilities and
and expanding the need these basically
are programs that help
people with disabilities to be able to
participate in the workforce without
losing benefits and
with as a result of earning some
additional income
the benefits of being able to to be
engaged
in your community without the risk of
of losing benefits with a little bit of
additional income is kind of the key
thing here
me just for people who are less than 64
and less
mode is for adults
greater in mead we also
updated the financial
[Music]
eligibility requirements there and we'll
talk about a little bit that when we
get into some of the prioritized needs
that
weren't necessarily funded in the budget
so far
so one of uh representative weiler's not
here but one of the things
uh he he emphasizes in this is that
um if if you know that
the federal government has changed
eligibilities or that we're planning on
changing
eligibilities in a way in which it
increases our
financial obligations that you're
letting
you're letting us know in a in a
formal direct clear communication what
those
um eligibilities are and what your
anticipated impact
will be right we did we did do through
our fiscal notes
um and with the legislation it's just
that the funding didn't end up
following through um and we didn't have
control of that
ultimately well i'm talking in general
programs with all of them having
eligibilities if the eligibilities
change
in a way in which it's going to cost
more money or save us money
you're letting us know on all of them i
assume
yes and by statute there are certain
things that we have to take through
various committees of the legislature in
order to even um submit a state plan on
those
the next slide in terms of program
development
you know one of the major areas of focus
that we work on is a major part of
funding for the department comes from
the medicaid enhancement tax and the
the disproportionate share payments that
we make to uh
to hospitals um and basically in 2018
there was a
legislation passed in hb 1817 to
put together an agreement between the
state and the providers and
and the rules that have to be followed
there are governed
by both state and federal
authority changes and as those things
change we have to work to
to modify the program to continuous
compliance
we also have reporting obligations um
which we work with
the medicaid finance unit and complying
with with the granite advantage program
i heard before the meeting started that
there's a committee that some of you may
be participating on in terms of
evaluating
the granite advantage program and those
are the types of things that we would
help
provides information to the committee on
non-emergency medical transportation is
an area that
is part of the recent reprocurement
[Music]
was was bid out differently than it had
been historically
um and implemented that and i'm also
um proud to say that uh our team um
brook belanger in particular uh
supported the eoc and standing up
in less than two weeks time the
transportation to support the
non-medicaid benef
individuals in the state who otherwise
wouldn't be able to have transportation
to get
vaccinated and that program kicked off
this weekend in particular um
mmis is an area that we'll spend some
more time with but
for most of this past fiscal year we've
operated
with some significant staff vacancies
and we'll talk about that more
later and then lastly on this slide is
operationalizing the maternal opiate
misuse
model grant that we received um
manchester medical community coming to
the state to help them
be eligible to apply for two grants and
um these have both recently gone through
um both fiscal committee and governor
and council
we had a delay because of the the kovit
19 situation the first
people that will be enrolled and this
will be in
july but basically the idea is to
support uh moms and the care of their
children
who may be addicted to opioids
i see representative you have a question
representative yeah representative irv
thank you mr chairman since you're on
this topic since you mentioned it
can you remind me what the source of
funds is for the advantage the grant
the granite advantage program sure
and the granite advantage program the
federal government kicks in 90 then
there is
10 percent non-federal share and really
there
are that non-federal share component the
is derived from several sources
the premium taxes on the policies
themselves
is one source
[Music]
five percent of gross liquor
profits is another source and
the new hampshire health plan which
historically was the high risk pool
that they contribute amount up to the
what those other two sources uh generate
so the liquor fund five percent
and the premium tax that that uh
those monies are kicked in to come up
with a ten percent
there was also legislation passed last
session that that wasn't
sufficient that additional liquor funds
could be accessed
and that turned out to be uh timely from
the standpoint of the
surge in enrollment as a result of the
public health emergency
but that should back off when enrollment
goes back to
historic levels do you have to know the
rsa that
specifies all of that um i do
[Music]
and just to make sure i uh give it to
you correctly uh
um i'll ask uh athena if uh
gag didn't make sure to uh maybe if we
could bring her on if she has but i
think it's rsa 126
double a 3 is where you'll find that
okay so just so you know
um uh mr lemon uh we're gonna
we're gonna break for lunch uh when
we're through with your slides
so if anyone's getting hungry they can
blame you
the challenges facing the department
so public health emergency and how long
that's going to last
creates a lot of uncertainty um in terms
of predicting
impacts um and
then we've as we'll talk about a little
bit more later we have substantial
vacancies that we've been
contending with while at the same time
expanding the scope of work that we need
to do and then
lastly in terms of the unwind of the
public health emergency if
we want to keep those people who are
eligible enrolled
as the public health emergency unwinds
but those people who aren't eligible
that we also need to disenroll those
people who aren't
eligible any further at the end of the
public health emergency because
you know it costs 500 roughly per person
per month
and if you had 20 000 people who weren't
eligible as an example i'm not saying
that's the number but if you did that's
like 10 million dollars of expense total
funds
and so it's important that we
work to um what i described is avoiding
a tsunami at the end of the public
health emergency of working through
enrollment and eligibility issues that
we're working at all along the way
and um so that's one area that we're
spending um
we've been planning uh and working on
for for many many months now
and uh is a high priority to make sure
that
um in terms of some workload things it's
[Music]
currently um in terms of
medicaid staffing today we have 19 staff
in the division of medicaid services
and fully staffed including what was in
the governor's budget
including the temporary positions would
be 35
and you know based on um
on that you can see where we have some
some holes and we'll talk about those a
little bit
in terms of beneficiaries typical
thing that is looked at as a ratio of
beneficiaries to staff
you know today we're operating at over
11 000 beneficiaries to
to division of medicaid staff you know
if we were fully staffed we'd be
operating almost half of that
now you ask how does that compare to the
rest of the world
i think you can find that new hampshire
is probably
on the upper end of staff too meaning
that we have
less staff compared to beneficiaries but
it was really it's a hard statistic to
compare because
how a department of health and human
services organized a different state
you know like for example the state of
vermont is is organized
as a fifa service program and they may
have
their for example their division of
finance may be combined with their
division of medicaid in
our department of health and human
services you know legal
and and fine and finance are organized
under their respective
um if you will uh expert areas so that
you know all the finance people are
under a finance department which i think
makes the most sense
to make sure that um you know the right
supervision and quality
is there but uh it's this just gives us
a little bit of sense that we've been
dealing with some vacancies
um we talked about earlier in this
middle slide here that
if before you hit the middle slide
representative earth had a question
yeah mr clerk i'm having a hard time
keeping up with you i apologize for that
um a couple slides ago the manage the
medicaid managed care
program you mentioned two two things
about provider rates
december 2019 you implemented a 3.1
percent increase and then
the first of this year or this year i
guess yes
another one so are those is that
basically six percent of our time are
those going to different groups and it's
3.1 percent to different groups
so the legislation that was passed was
uh across the board for providers a 3.1
percent increase
so it affected nursing homes home health
care providers
committee mental health centers fqhcs
hospitals
doctors um psychologists all
all different areas of the department
that you know we have 30
000 providers that are enrolled in the
medicaid program
and um you know all the different
categories of providers receive some
type of rate increase if they were a
licensed
or supervised by a licensed medical
provider
so so those are two sequential increases
one yes
one just this year right thank you very
much
and before we get on that i i want to
jump to the end
um so to keep moving you
you our mms i think mm-is i think he
said we
have 100 vacancy in this area
yes so so what are you what are you
doing to maintain the systems and
and what what's getting in the way of
recruiting people to
to manage this system so
if i could take the last one first there
was a hiring freeze
it was one aspect in terms of being able
to recruit them recently we've been
authorized to hire for the positions
that are available
you know we operate this system in
collaboration with the department of
i.t um the oit and so
in terms of if you will the hardware and
maybe
it might be a good time to bring in um
david weeder's but you know basically
there's if you will the technical
performance of the system and then
there's if you will the applications
it's really the the application and
business development side of things that
um we were tremendously short-handed and
we've
we've had um one um vendor consultant
that we've been using to try to
um keep us keep us afloat in this time
period of the
hiring freeze and and so forth but uh
you know we we've if you will
underfunded last
uh uh last budget
uh appropriation we've had to find
funds within the department to to try to
maintain it we
will talk about in a moment that we had
risks
around the federal match percentage but
if if you're okay with it i think
jumping if you want to get into mmis the
next two slides i think would be
good once to to dive into it and david
i'd like to
take the lead on that if you're okay
with that jim
before we get going uh representative
walner had a question i think on this
slide
well i no actually it go it goes back to
um
what representative earth was asking
about um the
rate increase that was in the previous
budget in the previous budget
is there any rate increase in for
providers in this budget
for the next two years there is not
um in the division that i oversee there
i believe you'll see in ltss there may
be some
okay but but none none for two years
and actually they will have gone
since the last rate increase was what
january of
21 yes
so they will have gone 27 months
at least before there would be any sort
of rate increases for these services
representative i'm i'm i'm curious why
you didn't ask if they'd requested it
and the governor's
office didn't fund it that's that sounds
like a normal question you ask
i guess i was just a little a little uh
asleep at the wheel like
okay mr mr lipman did you request a rate
increase
um we we did not uh based on
um you know funding what we already
had in place that it was uh particularly
at the time we were preparing the agency
budget and the
shortfalls that were forecasted for the
for the state that um practically uh
maintaining what we had was going to be
thank you we can uh i'm sorry to just go
skim over your second slide but i think
we can read it and it's
kind of self-explanatory so we can go to
26.
okay i think this would be our plan was
to have david lead this and i'll add
some commentary as he goes through those
two slides
can you minimize your slide just a
little bit because the way it's
zoomed now it's it's exceeds the screen
there you go
okay sorry about that thank you for
letting me know
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee my name is david weeders i'm
the information services director for
health and human services and our goal
was to go
dive into the medicaid management
information system
the current state and where we're going
with the system in this next biennium
please let me know and i'm aware of the
process for questions
so representative edwards mr chair i
will recognize you
waving your hand as you go through thank
you so this system
has gone through what we call an
application lifecycle management over
the last
16 years so back in 2005 we
identified the system design of how we
wanted to implement
the mmis system we worked with the
center for medicaid medicare and
medicaid services
for that system design and went out to
rfp
and initially purchased the hardware and
software in 2007
after reward that was the last time that
we actually
acquired hardware and software up until
this past year where we did acquire
some hardware and and some software
associated with what we call a technical
stack
upgrade that capital project was funded
at about 26 million dollars of the
original 90 million dollars that we
requested to
manage this system in 2013 we went live
with the system
six years after procuring the hardware
and software
due to many different reasons current
the original design was for a fee for
service
solution over time we also we migrated
to a managed care
in this state which required lots of
changes
along the way as well as federal and
state mandates that required some
changes in the system and of course
the final complexity of it as well two
years later in 2015 the system was
certified
and certification is a key component for
federal matching dollars
as it relates to our maintenance and
operations of these systems
so prior to being certified we had a 50
match for for the maintenance and
operations after certification
we received an additional 25 percent
which equates to about 6.6 million
dollars in
federal matching funds reducing our
general fund
impact by that amount
as we as we have heard recently
this system is our core system to
process medicaid claims
provider services it also includes
third-party liability
um components from our other division
for quality
program and program integrity as well as
does the basic functions of mailroom
processing of reports
and call center functionality for the
when you look at this yes i thought
you're about to go to the next slide
go ahead i'll try this i have a question
on this slide before you go to the next
one
certainly um so just from a overall
perspective our current contract expires
this june
and we're anticipating an extension of
that contract for five years
to support our reprocurement efforts so
this system
based off of researching different types
of reprocurement strategies and
working with other states within the
country as well as
looking at different functions of
leveraging the national association of
state procurement officers or looking at
regionalized government to
reduce our costs we've identified a
five-year plan
to replace the system through a modular
reprocurement
cms or center for medicare medicare
medicaid services
has a recommendation that we would do a
modular re-procurement
and has supported many other states in
that effort
that five-year plan requires us to
maintain our existing system
and so in the operating budget for that
you're looking at today
that actually shows the increased cost
to maintain
the existing system as well as ensure
that we're not
seeing a spike in hardware and software
purchases
throughout the time period the goal of
that
is to really flatten that that
investment in the mmis the current mmis
system
and not have any surprises when it comes
to hardware and software going forward
will i'll go ahead and stop there on
this slide um for any questions
so thanks mike my question there is over
this next five year cycle
will some of the mi mmis
functionality be able to move to
software as a service
model to get us less in the hardware
business that's a very good question mr
chair
certainly our goal is to look at
software as a service modules as they
come available
for instance the provider services mod
module that the national association of
state procurement officer did a
a fairly large multi-state bidding
process that we could use as a
participating agreement
awarded to six different vendors of
which two or more of them
provide shops with some of them still
host their own server and software in
their own call center
which you can consider a private cloud
but not necessarily the
software as a service that you're
looking for all of which
all of our future ones would be looking
at a subscription type software as a
service module and i'm not a fan of the
regionalized government approach
but it doesn't sound like that's what
that's when you've considered you're
just not going that way
that is correct mr chair currently when
we looked at the regionalized government
it required a lot of either one of two
different things
and so you need normally have a lead
agency
and a follow in following agencies or
lead state and following states
the lead state has a large investment in
no that's all right if we're not going
to do it
we don't need to spend time on it but i
think thank you
um or i don't see any other questions on
this slide
we can go to the next slide
so as i discussed earlier the mmis is
a very complex system it's com it
composes several different modules which
you see across the top of your slide
there
those are just the high level modules
there are several other modules included
in the mmis but the the core of the
system is a claims processing system
we we look at this and we get our
direction
primarily from state and federal
legislation
and we need to address our five-year
plan in terms of
the priorities our current priorities
right now is to be able to
maintain our federal reporting um
address some of our pain points and
provider services
and call center management as well as
as go into what you heard maybe last
week i guess i believe
a third party liability module
i'm going to kick it over to henry
briefly to go over the some of the key
benefits of this system
and then i have a i have a technical
question before you give it to mr
lippman
um so so historically
uh the concept of departmental systems
was essential because that's that's how
we grew right
we had a specific departmental need and
we solved it
increasingly i think the model is
intended to be
modular at the enterprise level so
as i'm looking at these modules i'm
seeing a call center
and federal reporting and maybe training
and communications
as names of
modules that could potentially
become enterprise level modules
so because everyone all departments have
to do some level of federal reporting
for example
so so my question is kind of a strategic
one
in the sense that when you're looking at
replacing the mmis with the more modular
saf saas model
or are i assume you're also looking at
more of an enterprise
concept than a departmental concept
could you could you speak to that
thank you mr chair that's a good
question actually falls into in our
into our strategic plan that we're
working on with department of
information technology
and leveraging platforms to not only
address the medicaid but also
other parts of our division and
potentially other parts of our state
we we actually plan on doing that kind
of platform approach
in the federal reporting certainly which
we already started about
three years ago um building our
enterprise business intelligence
platform
but we have not had a chance to fully
integrate or basically take out of the
mmis that component
this prod the next five years our goal
is to take that component out
and leverage that enterprise business
intelligence platform that
spans our entire department as well as
our partner agencies within the state
and then
continue that process of looking at
certainly call center training
communications
was another one and then the final one
that we we believe that we could
leverage
enterprise approach is the claims
processing we process claims in our
children youth and family
system our long-term supports and
services our child support as well as on
our medicaid and we believe that we can
leverage that one claims engine
with four different what we call
business rules and processes
from one vendor which will reduce our
our
footprint of systems over time does that
address your question mr chair
i i i love the concept and and hopefully
uh you guys will continue to work on
that in the strategic
plan so i think that
i think that's going to give us the best
solution at the least cost
uh and the greatest simplicity over time
so hopefully hopefully that'll that
vision pans out we agree and
we we are also hopeful for that vision
to pan out we we've seen
um quite a bit of effort and increa
improved
data quality in in leveraging the
enterprise approach for
for the enterprise business intelligence
we anticipated to
continue to enhance the medicaid program
by doing that as well as other modules
throughout this project any other
questions on this slide so unless you've
got
something you you you want to say that
you can continue or
give the mystery i would like to if i
could uh chairman um
just on the right side the penalty and
risk is that
what we're pointing out here is that um
without funding we would end up um
with a system um situation where
we're going to pay uh penalties that are
equal
to the cost of what we need to implement
that we haven't been able to implement
due to lack of funding
and also in terms of your constituent
services if you will that
you know 30 000 providers and 215 000
citizens depend on the system in one way
or another
and i think that um i think the
the point we're trying to make here on
the right-hand side is that
without adequate funding we're going to
end up you know
running the risk of um we're going to
have to come up with general funds of
uh somewhere around 6.6 million over the
biennium
as well as have a system that
potentially could lose its
compliance status and that will cost us
federal match so i
i just i i i need you to be a little
more clear with me
are you saying that you need money
that's not in the governor's budget and
we have to add it
no the money is in the governor's budget
we last
last uh biennium we were not funded for
projects that we know that we needed
and as a result of that uh the time
frame to implement things we're not
going to make those time frames
without approving what's in the
governor's budget we'll be at risk of
financial penalties
that are equal to or greater than what
the cost would be in general funds
if the governor's budget is funded we're
saying that the governor's
budget funding is very important
so you're also then saying that uh in
the fy
21 budget if we were to uh
freeze your funding at fy21 levels
uh you would not have enough money to
cover this
absolutely we would probably also run
the risk of losing certification and
take a
so that's good to know um
would you just send me a little note of
specifically what
line item this is and what the change is
from fy 21 to 22.
the bottom left-hand side i think when
we go through the line by line it'll
be fairly evident where it is and if
after that you still
need something i'll certainly provide it
for you so i'm still learning to swing
through the budget i know that i need a
a lot an accounting unit line number
somewhere and make sure that i'm i'm
tracing the right account
i'm going to make myself a note so then
we'll get to that point and karen's
going over things that we cover that
um if it's okay i can continue yes yes
i don't see any questions i think athena
was going to uh athena gagnon our
director of
medicaid finance was going to help
address this slide athena who
good morning so the first item that i'm
going to cover here is what we spoke
about earlier and that's the
funding the adult dental program we do
have a priority need we have a new
request
in the house where i'm actually lowering
the priority need in fiscal year 22
due to the change in the proposed
implementation date of april 1
as opposed to an implementation date of
september 1
of 22.
the other priority need that we need to
actually
revisit is funding the increased
cost of the pre-coveted enrollment if we
don't reach it
until march of 2022 as henry litman
mentioned earlier when we built the
budget in august we were actually
anticipating that our enrollment would
be at pre-covered levels
by july 1 of 2021
new indications of course with the
rollout of the vaccination
and the second surge that we saw during
the holiday season
we are anticipating in the governor's
budget
that the public health emergency period
will end in december of 2021
which would allow us 90 days to
disenroll those members
and we would reach pre-covered levels by
the third item that we also need funding
for again is something that mr whitman
mentioned earlier
and that is in relation to the mead
program
in funding the in and out
and that priority need in total funds
and general funds is listed
below
if we were to decrease our budget
there are some items that are listed
that are
obviously not recommended but they would
be eliminating coverage for the optional
eligibility groups
we could not make any changes to those
until after the public health emergency
period
same goes for optional covered services
now the top three being pharmacy
home and community based services and
community mental health
centers those are all listed in the
briefing book on pages 70 and 71
and then also just mentioned earlier is
the risk if the mmis
is not funded the risk certification
which um
david readers mentioned would be a
general fund
impact of 6.6 million annually
i guess i would emphasize that these are
things that we're not
recommending but in terms of trying to
reduce
uh based on the requirements of what a
mandatory services there's
not a lot of room um to to do things
other than things that really
would have a negative effect on on many
citizens of the state if you were to
recommend reducing your budget you would
be the first director i think in
u.s history to ever have done that so so
we
we're not breaking ground on that today
hey but i did want to say
uh this is the uh about the
eighth or ninth time we've seen a slide
like this and this is really the most
developed
um so so thank you it's the most useful
[Music]
i'm fortunate to have an excellent
finance director and working with athena
very experienced and
on the on the next slide kind of shows
the
the the team um that's within the
division
um well athena is technically in the
finance division
um she's a key player to making the
division of medicaid services
work in terms of budget and policy
issues that require
money is the size of the slide okay
can you see this okay sure oh yeah it's
great
so just in terms of the the team i'm
fortunate to have a lot of
good people that have been able to and
willing to step
up and do go above and beyond
dealing with a lot of the vacancy issues
that we've had
um there's my role as the the director
and again
consultant to many other divisions and
supporting
team if you will it's a as i say
medicaid is a definitely a team sport in
terms of
both within the division and uh within
the department of health and human
services
um you've met uh dr finney um
who is our our dental director
is a licensed dentist
we have a position called the director
of medicaid enterprise development which
is
brook belanger brook
comes to the department having at one
point in her career been
head of the medicaid fraud unit for the
attorney general's office
and had worked as a compliance officer
in for a major health system in new
hampshire
she's a lawyer by background and but her
role
is trying to um make sure all the
different
if you will silos and pieces of the
medicaid system sort of
are harmonized so that things work the
way they're supposed to we work with
you know meredith tell us unit as well
in terms of the program integrity
and elisa cohen is my deputy um she's
been here
two years came and originally on the
granite advantage healthcare program
waiver and she's going to be the deputy
she helps me in a lot of areas of
running the
uh is comes to us with a policy
background having worked
in um new york state government uh
actually in the
city of new york and working for a large
health system
um and uh then underneath that uh we
have mco
operations on the left here shirley
acappino who's been with the department
five years
um she and laura ringleberg uh run our
mco operations again they help
coordinate and supervise uh day-to-day
activities within the mco program
jane hipps who is our clinical lead
again there she uh operates she's a
nurse
uh by training she's uh my most senior
person in
the department she
is oversees the clinical aspects of the
medicaid school program she
oversees prior authorizations and parts
of the
in the fifa service side of state plan
services
she's a consultant on clinical issues
that come up
around the mco operations in terms of
working out for example
when we were going to handle um a public
health emergency in terms of prior
authorizations and things like that
how to harmonize that so we would have
them
the um at least impact on
on providers when they were tremendously
stressed as well as making sure it
worked for our beneficiaries
um don landry who's been with us 28
years
overseas the the policy unit um
oversees the state plan work we
had someone who retired
who had been with us over 40 years who
oversaw a state plan and
she's helped fill in that gap
tremendously during this time
but all the eligibility uh rules and
regulations which there are
their their feet thick if you will in
terms of what we have to comply with don
is our lead on that we also have a
pharmacy director we have two
pharmacists
peg clifford and
elise ferrand works with her both long
tenured
people in the department that oversee
our pharmacy
benefits of the state and the most
recent procurement went to a
what we call a single uh
pharmacy drug list pharmaceutical drug
list and
that's a recommended practice uh to help
with pharmacy costs from a financial
standpoint as well as from
a rebate standpoint and helping improve
that for the state
we had a director of provider relations
which we
person retired during early 2020
and that position again helps us
interface with
the 30 000 providers we actually have
two vacancies currently in that unit
and brooke belanger has been helping
fill
in some of that role we also have
an administrator of our federal waivers
in which that position is also vacant
and then we talked about mmis where
all these positions are currently uh
vacant and
we have again one consultant and uh
the support of doit who's gone above and
beyond to keep us
functioning during this time i don't
know if there are any questions on the
organizational structure here um and the
people we have one
sure so
okay so in the military we made a
distinction between
faces and spaces a space was just the
head count
and the line item and the face was the
actual person
and so i i i do not want to talk about
the person i just want to talk about the
position
sure the dental director position
if we've not had a medicaid dental
program
what drove the need to have a dental
director
position and is it a full-time position
well we we cover over 90 000 children in
the dental program
if you remember we what we're asking for
approval for is an adult dental benefit
so you did it thanks
uh representative weiler is back now
thank you sir
so uh this slide let me make sure you
it's good okay um basically uh
the left-hand side is the list of
positions
and the the governor's budget there's
also two temporary positions which are
footnoted
in the mmis areas temporary the
next column is our vacancies
[Music]
and then the vacancy rate in those
positions and then
just kind of the the general description
of kind of where they fit
under our um medicaid services
just suffice it to say we the mmis whole
is
very important to to fill um
and we're struggling with the
you know in the clinical area and
the provider relations area in
particular
uh with the workload and you know
rolling out new benefits and having
fewer people and and greater enrollment
so
these are i think are very important
positions i think the governor saw as
well in his
proposed budget well if you
pay more than 100 a year i'll start
monday
and henry could i just jump in there for
a half a second
so one of the things i wanted to mention
chair and i know that the report is
outstanding still
and as soon as it is public i will have
it to the committee
uh but one of the things that alvarez
and marcel looked at
was staffing across the department but
especially staffing and medicaid and
comparing it to
some of our neighboring states and
compared to some of our neighboring
states we
most certainly run leaner in our
medicaid department
so that's just something of note thank
you
and speaking of the end of the m a
report
when one what's the most current
estimate for
for when we can get our uh our first
secret copy of it so unfortunately i
can't provide you a secret copy of it i
will provide you the document as soon as
it is public
um i i don't want to promise you a date
and then not meet it uh
i really don't like to do that i i hope
it'll be this week but
i think karen you're gonna pick up from
here
or is it am i right on that or athena
i don't see athena unmuting so i'll go
ahead um and just speak to it
of course medicaid budget is one of our
largest budgets
so um well this although this chart
lays out all of the information i don't
know that um
it's the most helpful to to see it this
way i think
looking at each of the accounting units
is probably going to be a lot more
helpful but this does give you
a little bit of sense of the overall
budget
what's the overall issue between the
expansion
of of general funds in the current
budget
and the reduction in general funds in
the next budget
what's just the general story the one
sentence uh so the general funds are
actually increasing they're the
the red um piece of the chart
uh uh i
would say half of that is related to the
dcyf
costs coming over into the medicaid
somewhere in that range but you'll see
more of that as we go through the actual
budget
and the federal matching percentage
change right
right and the federal matching percent
just in terms of federal matching this
is just a
reference slide for you in terms of you
know how the federal match is determined
nationally as has to do with per capita
incomes and
so we said earlier in the slot earlier
in the
presentation that new hampshire's
minimum is 50
um but some states like you know
mississippi comes to mind
you know that are um the poorer states
um get a higher match and that's just
there's nothing we can do about that
it's a statutory thing at a federal
level
so mississippi has a higher proportion
of federal money to state money because
of their higher need
is that what you just said correct their
poverty in particular
the you can see the northeast is tends
to be lighter
in terms of uh new hampshire's
has poverty that needs to be addressed
for sure but
you know relatively we're compared to
the rest of the country you know we're
economically as is massachusetts
connecticut rhode island
um in better shape
[Music]
and we put together a slide again this
is sort of a reference slide for you
um in terms of the different federal
matching rates
at different time periods if you'd like
us to
to dive into this a little bit be
willing to do so but i just
wanted to give you something here in the
interest of time that shows how the
federal matching rate
changes under the enhancement and how
the enhancement changes over time
[Music]
thank you mr chairman can you speak to
how you intend
to share the benefit of the enhanced
federal match with
the medicaid providers in particular the
counties and all the county lines not
just the
not just the nursing home line
so the i guess the short answer is it's
it's not a simple
um response i think as as you know
because you serve on it there's a
county and state finance committee
that's looking at it with respect to the
county cap but the intent of the
enhanced fmap is to cover the expanded
population we have as i
mentioned earlier you know a 21.5
percent
increase in total enrollment
and that comes with some cost and
so that um you know in terms of covering
the increased enrollment the the
published studies on this for example
the kaiser foundation
does not expect at least to the this
point the enhanced fmap to cover states
costs in total
in terms of the expanded enrollment and
expanded utilization
i think i'll let karen maybe add to that
explanation
if she would like to but i think
generally the enhanced
f map is intended to cover the expanded
population that you have to cover
and is also sort of the you know at the
time that
it ends um the public health emergency
ends we're obligated to
provide uh coverage to the end of that
month and
um i think that's uh
that's kind of the story to this point
that could be um i think over time
um you know we've identified for example
in the county area that
you know there is by statute a
percentage that
that the counties are responsible for if
if the fmap goes
on for a certain amount of time that
it would potentially become a credit
available i know there are other
discussions there that i don't want to
get ahead of but i think in general that
the additional f maps intended to cover
the additional enrollment
and and again that for many states the
additional f map might not cover
all the additional enrollment costs
thank you
know karen if you want to add to that at
all i guess the only thing i would add
is that the
the county funds are not in the medicaid
budget they're in the long term supports
and services budget which we will cover
go ahead so yeah no i thank you i'm just
trying to um
form the question so they are medicaid
services or no
yes it is medicaid uh but because
they're
for long-term supports like nursing
facilities we
we do have that within the long-term
supports budget as well as
like the uh the dd budget is also
medicaid it's a medicaid waiver
and that is in with the long-term
supports and services budget we if we
lumped that all into one budget
more than half of dhhs's budget would be
there are 16 accounts that have some
level of medicaid participation that's
what i was
speaking at the beginning that we both
run a program and provide support to
other divisions in the department to be
able to draw medicaid funds
for their programs so just so i
understand what you're saying
the medicaid component actually shows up
in many different budgets it doesn't
necessarily say medicaid with it
um apparently how the the different
units um designate the medicaid
component in their budgets but i might
let you or or athena answer that part of
the question
or so as far as medicaid services
like paying a provider for the most part
that is
in the medicaid budget and in the long
term supports and services budget
there might be a little bit in other
areas of the department but that was
as we spoke about moving the dcyf
medicaid costs into standard medicaid
that was part of trying to consolidate
that
when it comes to medicaid administration
that is probably in
75 of the accounting units across the
department
right my salary is partially paid with
medicaid administration
the commissioners is et cetera et cetera
but
as far as paying providers for the most
part it's in those two budgets
representative it sounds like you're
satisfied
yes thank you all right so
we can go on and just i want to give a
i'm sorry i want to give a heads up to
the folks who are listening in the
attendees
i see several of you who are
expected guests on wednesday afternoon
i'm looking forward to talking to you
then
if there's any attendee that has a short
comment to make to help
the committee make some of these
decisions we have to make
uh you'll you'll get an opportunity here
in a moment to raise your hand
and i'd like to like you to keep it
short if you do have something to say
all right so so go ahead sorry for the
interruption and i think we're ready to
close out
so the last two slides are really the
the detail i think you're looking to
walk through
um after you have your lunch break which
is the
unit by unit uh line by line items
i think uh where we've done i think with
what
we needed to share with you um unless
there are further questions on
the prize slides i just have a general
question and we will dive into the
details but the idn
fund yes what what what do we think
we're buying
with an idn fund so when the new budget
there's there's no money in the budget
for that
in terms the reason that's still in
there is because of the history
uh aspect of of it and so there are zero
funds
requested and zero funds appropriated in
the governor's budget
for uh 22-23 the waiver ended
december 31st of of 21 there is a
run-out period that runs through the
state fiscal year
uh 21 but there won't be expenses in 20
right uh are there any questions at this
point
okay uh are there anyone in the
attendees that have something to share
for the good
of the cause uh if not we're gonna go to
uh
to lunch and we'll break until 12
30 i think i'm not seeing any hands up
do you see any hands up mr ripple and
the
so um i i'm proposing we uh take a lunch
break until 12 30.
does anyone think they need more time
than that
speak up if you do all right
so let's uh i will put our hearing into
recess
karen do you need me to share no i will
share as soon as the chair is ready
okay okay so being 12 30 and being
that hopefully everyone's had enough
time to
eat a satisfying lunch we're ready to
get into the financials of the medicaid
area and
oh wait wait uh representative irf has
an initial question yes sir
i just that's a question touching on
what we end with last
you talked about the fmap is here um
expansion that that was where the costs
were
what is that expansion who's in that
expansion population
so um the way the maintenance of effort
is anybody who as of the date of the
start of the public health emergency
remains
covered by medicaid through the end of
the public health emergency
regardless of whether there's a change
in circumstance or not that
has a national policy that to make sure
that people have health insurance
coverage
through the pandemic that um if
if we ordinarily would have a churn of
maybe like 2500 people a month
we we don't have that because of the
maintenance of effort requirement
okay but still i'm not who is it what
what i mean
you you implied it wasn't people in
nursing homes so who is it
it is it is people um and long-term
services and support it's every
every category if you go back to the
um trying to think of what slide it was
in the slide deck
um give me one second here it's
basically just
everyone who at the date of the
emergency was in medicaid
for whatever eligibility reason
continues with medicaid
throughout regardless of change
circumstances
right if you go to slide 11
representative earth of the
slide deck that was this morning that
shows you each of the the categories the
the growth in that so it was
but just on a global level of the 37 000
increase you know a good percentage of
those
are um are people from the moe
and about a little more than half are a
granted advantage
um and then the other part is the
standard population and again i think
the maps also give you a little bit of
insight into that as well
can i follow up does does that
is that slide specifically talking about
the
enhanced f now that's the slide
of people that have remained on medicaid
or or how
the population growth has gone in um but
we could
do something different in terms of i
think your precise question may be is
how many people are are the moe
category we don't exactly know that
number um
because we don't haven't seen whether
people's circumstances have changed or
not
entirely i i'm not really looking for
the what i'm trying to understand i the
implication
you in your previous comments about when
i
was asking you about the nursing homes
in those facilities
when you spoke about the expanded fmap
the implication to me that i heard
saying was that that's not where the
extra expense was
it was some is some other age group some
other
group of people not the ones who are in
the nursing homes or in those other
long-term facilities so
can you just clarify that for me sure so
as an example in medic
medicaid the health insurance program as
an example
we were operating at 177 000 or so
individuals before the start of the
public health emergency
um we had to increase our contract
limitation for example the mco program
by almost a half a billion dollars
initially to account for the extra
enrollment um
that was going to be in that that
program and so
if you're talking about nursing home we
do know that the number of missions
because of
covid went down but in home and
community-based services and other
parts of the medicaid budget there are
increases in enrollment so someone
in the nursing home um
nursing home days went down you're right
you're correct about that
no okay so as long as you prime that
area um
i i'm um i'm curious if
we are doing any if there's any way for
us
to track people whose circumstances have
changed
that need to be disenrolled or you know
how
it sounded to me like you already were
aware of some that
that are candidates for disenrollment
once the emergency is order
over but uh to what extent do we have
visibility into that population
so we have visibility into for example
people
like children that age out of the
children's category we have visibility
of people who
are maybe wearing granite advantage and
age
and agent to medicare as their primary
so those are types of things we have
visibility on
whether someone's income for example has
changed
we have some visibility on on that for
certain groups of people where
we can access uh certain databases
federal databases and
state databases but for other people we
don't know
um but we know for example today there
are about
18 000 um redeterminations that
that where we're waiting or we need to
know which is about half the population
of the 37 000 increase we're waiting to
see um
you know whether at the time the public
health emergency ends whether
for whatever reason would they continue
or not continue to to qualify and that's
a
when i was talking about the end of the
public health emergency and the
unwinding we have to sort through
that group to make sure that people who
aren't eligible don't continue but those
who are
most importantly particularly the
vulnerable mentally ill and
other disabilities that we make sure
that people who are eligible remain
eligible and that's a
one of our biggest i think tasks and um
again i think when
um there's a ability to share the a
m report you'll see that they have some
comment on that as well
so 18 000 redeterminations
that sounds like easily six to 12 months
worth of workload
um we're not going to be able to uh
we're not going to be able to let it
take that long we're doing pre-work we
want to do it considerably shorter time
than that
representative edwards uh we uh you know
we're trying to target it to get it done
um within the quarter that um that the
federal
match is available is is kind of what
we're working towards
operationally all right sounds
sounds uh sounds great thank you um
are there any other questions before we
start to to break out the financial
sheets
okay i think we're ready great
all right so uh just going to the end of
henry's presentation you'll see here
the first account accounting unit is the
mom grant which is
on page 989 accounting unit
chair if you're speaking we can't hear
you i i'm just letting you know i i
surf to that part of my spreadsheet
so i can see it more easily
so this looks like it's all federal
funds and the federal funds are about to
grow dramatically
that's what we anticipate i do believe
that this is a grant that's awarded
annually so you know it's possible um
that things will change but this is what
we're anticipating
okay why are these several pages do we
show
there are no employees associated with
this grant the the employees that help
manage this grant are in the
medicaid administrative accounting unit
thank you there there is actually one
position that's tied to this grant
and it is in class 59 thank you
and i just want to add to you that this
grant was awarded um
january of 2020.
so how many how many moms do we think we
can
service with 750 000
of federal money we're
i think targeting approximately 300
okay does that also mean we have 300
moms
who are pregnant and on who are also on
opioids or is this
a lot of prevention effort as well um
it could be both it could be someone who
is is using or someone that
is at risk but generally it's targeted
at those
who um from a net from a historical
standpoint looking at nas
babies uh those that are uh addicted on
birth
that we estimate at least on a
historical basis that you know between
200 and 300
uh births of potential um exposure
so what's the nature of this contract
we've got contract for program
services what what what kind of what
kind of scope is in that contract
so just from a bit of a background
standpoint it was the
manchester community came to the
department
to be able to apply for this federal
grant because they were applying for two
grants and they needed the state to be
the state medicaid program to be the if
you were the lead applicant
in it so um in large measure the funding
goes to the lead agency which was
if you will drafted from the greater
manchester medical community and that's
elliott hospital
there then would subcontract with other
medical providers in their um their
community and this is
not for direct services it's for the
coordination and development of
follow-up
an ordinary for example mom might get
six months of follow-up the idea here is
it'd be
two years of follow-up to help make sure
that if
they're on the right track and remaining
free
abuse so the follow-up uh
implies that they're getting some sort
of a counseling service
if for no other reason than to find out
what their
what their drug status is they may be
um receiving a counseling service but
that's not what this money's paying for
it's the
it's the part of tracking and
providing the care coordination to get
them to the various services that they
need those services are built to
medicaid
directly
okay are there any other questions about
this
i'm i'm not i'm not seeing any but to
your earlier question
uh represent me was it while or you
talking about personnel there is a
attempt full-time
budget line you know
okay i assume that's what's paying for
the the
the the help yes
and is that person employed in this
department or borrowed
manpower from a different department and
this is a cost transfer
new new to the program and previously
had worked in the department of health
and human services
but wasn't currently the position is not
now
vacant correct very good thank you
you have something you want to make sure
we know i think we've asked our
questions
great the next accounting is
5201 which is the idn fund as
uh henry has already talked about that
waiver has ended so this accounting unit
is no longer budgeted
okay i'm going to ask a similar question
to the one i asked earlier
what did we buy with this money because
we spent it looks like we
spent almost 11 million in
fy 20 and almo and budgeted 26 million
what did we think we were getting karen
did i address that
yeah please henry um so i think the
it was a five year uh uh demonstration
um and the things that we were able to
demonstrate
that are be carried forward um
are a number of different things that
the department is
um working on um
utilizing so for example um
the years of technology for
tracking admissions discharges and
transfers so that
when for example someone is admitted to
the state hospital
and that there be notification to their
provider that they've been
admitted or if they're going to be
discharged
it's a technology that is
widely used by the mcos the
various medical providers and you know
that being an example of where
acting sooner on admissions and
discharges prevent
readmissions the state hospital
allow for um connection to their regular
provider to
coordinate medical information to be
able to to provide
um better coordination of care to reduce
length to stay or reduce readmissions
that's kind of one track of things
that's a
a technology and a process another thing
was
the employment and expansion of
providers to treat substance use
disorder
there was some 300
expansion of providers that treated
sud there was coordination
with for example the correctional system
in some counties that
to once the treatment was
for example for sud was done in the
prison system to carry forward their
coordination
once they leave the prison system so a
lot of different features to
improve care coordination to improve
transitions of care to increase the
capacity of the labor workforce
those are just some of the things that
we've got from this i think that
you know care coordination and care
management are
are important aspects of of
of what happens to control um costs
and to for example in the earlier
analogy someone who's using the
emergency room
you know tens of maybe even hundreds of
times that
being able to provide insight to to
different uh
parts of the health care system to be
able to intervene
to get them to the right level the right
care at the right time right place
right cost if that's helpful
representative edwards oh
it is it's it's uh you you told me more
than i thought i
was asking and that was helpful um i
guess my last question here is
uh we in the budget for this year we
thought we were going to spend
3.3 million dollars and
that there was a 10 million dollar local
funds
uh i'm curious what those local funds
are
and if both those budget amounts are
going to be
spent or if they're going to be
underspin
so this is a bit of a complicated
question representative edwards but let
me
try to keep it simple here um part of
the financing of this waiver came
from county contributions and
obviously because of the pandemic
counties
are having some of their own financial
challenges so
some of what we expected to be able to
obtain as the non-federal share
were not expecting to obtain any further
funds from the counties
so against a waiver that at one point
could have been
110 million dollars it's probably going
to be closer to 75 or 80.
okay and so we are going to understand
we're going to how about the general
funds are you are we
returning some amount of that to the
treasury well there there aren't um
the way this waiver was structured we
were receiving money for
um in certain programs um
in the department in behavioral health
public health
where the feds gave us money for
areas that they would not otherwise
typically match and
so in in other parts of the budget we're
gonna have to make up for the fact those
funds will no longer be coming to us
they were
expected to be temporarily um and that's
what they are
i think what i just heard you say is yes
we're going to spend the full 3.3
million
and because we didn't match enough on
the federal money
we're going to have to come up with some
more money in this budget year to
transfer over
um henry can i can i jump in
so as far as fiscal year 21. i don't
think that we're going to expend all
that 3.2 but what i can tell you is that
we have shortfalls elsewhere in the
department that we're transferring
general funds around but our overall
lapse for dhhs is expected to be in
excess of 75 million dollars
for fiscal year 21. um as far as 22 and
23 this gets back to a question
that representative earth asked and is
still an outstanding item that i'm
working on
uh which was a behavioral health
question and
the general funds had increased and the
question was why did the general funds
increase what happened to the federal
funds
this that was related to this program so
the general funds that are budgeted here
in fiscal year 21
are budgeted elsewhere and 22 and 23.
i think what henry is also saying is
because this was a half of the year
this is only half of the year the
general funds that were moved elsewhere
however uh in fiscal year 21 those
behavioral health contracts would have
been budgeted knowing
that the uh waiver was ending so there's
not additional funds
general funds needed um but these
general funds will be moved elsewhere
okay all right well that was that that
was more
what i was expecting to hear that kind
of an answer uh
fundamentally i'm just looking at 26
million dollars and it was a
demonstration
project but i'm i wonder what was
demonstrated that was worth 26 million
dollars but
we can go on okay right the next
accounting unit is 7937 which is
medicaid
administration this is where the
medicaid employees are budgeted
including the mmis employees
and karen also the
[Music]
the transfer to other state agencies
being in the state hospital with the
dish
yes yes the line 49 is the transfer to
new hampshire
hospital their dish payment is reflected
there so
in new hampshire hospital they receive
it as other income
it's received as federal income here in
i'm going to take a second and look at
this are there any oh lots of questions
representative waller um on that line
karen on the transfer
why is it so much more what what's the
increase
what's causing that increase athena can
you speak to that at all or would we
just
what we need to get that info from joe
yeah that's
that's something that we budget based on
joe's projections
symbol are you making that line 49 is
that the line we're talking about
yes okay and that line 49 is 100
federal there are no general funds in
that line
because the the match to the federal
funds for new hampshire hospital are
essentially in kind it's the general
funds that are spent at new hampshire
hospital
and actually dish doesn't have a general
fund match now that i
say that out loud okay so
the 14 million dollar increase
i mean that's great if it's 14 million
dollar increase in federal funds
i just wondered why what what was the
formula what caused it to
increase so much why why did the federal
government decide
to increase that so much i don't think
it's based on the federal government
it's based on a calculation of
uncompensated care so
what i'll do jonah if you can just put
that on the questions i'll make sure to
have joe
um provide that information as to the
increase
thank you thank you any more follow-ups
representative
if i could just back up for a moment
karen
1371 did that exist in the previous
the maternal opioid misuse uh it only
existed when it was created when they
we accepted the grant funds it was not
created during the budget process
i think we tried to create it during the
budget process and kevin told me i was
too late
if i recall correctly we got the grant
award i want to say
super late in that second year
yeah oh so we were actually in the
continuing resolution
that was a federal fund grant is it yes
thank you
weiler
you're on mute sir the next
you show editions of one classified and
unclassified with 22 and 23.
is that because of the increases in
things or
who would we add unclassified
athena do you know which uh position was
which unclassified position was that
brooks position that was transferred
i believe it was brooks yes okay so
it came from somewhere else in the
budget i don't remember what that who
held that position before her it might
have been
um as far as the permanent position
increase is that moving from somewhere
else or is that the conversion
because we abolished a position
yeah that's actually a number of things
you're you're fading out um the last
few seconds was just completely faded
out
sorry is that better oh yeah okay good
so uh part of that are the mmis
positions that were previously
unfunded in 20 and 21 in addition to
we also moved in two or three other mmis
positions that should have been moved in
they were unfunded we moved them in in
22-23
thank you no more follow-up there
representative no thanks all right
sorry thank you so on
line 102 contract for program services
it's increased by about five million
dollars i was wondering
what new contracts or what is that sure
so
this is um contract funds that really
are to support the entire department but
i anticipate that it will come from
medicaid
at administration funding so i put it
all here but these would be the contract
funds
to support the transformation projects
in house bill 2. so the funds in house
bill 2
the 10 million dollars in general funds
with with the authority to accept any
uh federal funds those are to pay for
the
projects themselves right to implement
the it
processes to hire temporary employees
this fund is to hire a contractor to
help us support
that transformation so project manage
and and research and analysis and all of
follow-up great yeah uh so karen
are you talking about in house bill 2
are you talking about
the alvarez and marcel
the the contract with them is that what
we're talking about
so the 10 million dollars that's in hb2
is not to contract with
alvarez and marcel it's to implement the
projects that alvarez and
marcel is suggesting we implement which
is
the um the imd waiver
and the uh the projects within
behavioral health as well as the
dd system uh transformations
that so that's for the actual department
cost of making those changes
and this is to hire a contractor whether
it's alvarez marcel or another
contractor to help us to help support us
in making those transitions
so um this is an addition this is a new
10 million dollars
to do the things that alvarez and marcel
had in their review
yes so if
if i'm following this
then that is 10 million dollars
we spent last year but last year we
spent 7
800 in the year before we sent 5 million
so there's only 2 million
700 left what are we what aren't we
doing
if we took the 10 million out for the
for the alvarez and
marcel we would have 2 million left
what are we not doing nope so the
the funds in addition here the 7 million
to 12 million
is about uh 6 million a year
the 10 million that i was talking about
is an hb2
this is a separate appropriation the 6
million in hb1
okay just less than the 7.8 really
bringing it back in line to
what we actually spent around six a
little over six
do you have a follow-up um i'm just i'm
just
thinking about it for a minute um we get
a list
of what exactly we're doing with um
with the 10 million dollars that's in
house bill 2.
sure what i can do is provide a an
explanation of our plan
the part of the problem is that we still
have planning to do
um and so the what you'll see in the
alvarez marcel report are ranges
to implement many of these things and
for
many of them we chose a number that was
sort of in the middle of the range
but the reason part of the reason that
it's in hb2 and
and matt the governor's budget director
alluded to this
is that we're not sure exactly where
everything is going to land so the
governor's office was trying to give us
some flexibility to say you need to
implement all of these things
but it could be that um implementing the
imd waiver ends up a little more
expensive than we anticipated but one of
the other things that we're implementing
ends up costing a little bit less
so that's the reason that they put it in
hb2 to offer
us some flexibility around that but i
can definitely give you
um the projects that we're looking to
implement with that with those funds
thank you you're welcome so i have a
question for mr ripple and then we'll go
to
um uh representative weiler nerf so
so mr ripple this weekend as you were
working
hard during the weekend your off hours
one of the emails that you sent me
sounded like you were going to take the
hb2
items and put it into a spreadsheet so
that we could
see where we thought those hp2 items
were lining up
so are you are you going to be
aggregate or gross uh allocation
against any of these budget areas or are
you just going to do an overall
here's 10 million dollars associated
with a m
i was going to do an overall because the
10 million dollars for
alvarez and marcel for example i don't
know where that would be distributed
throughout the department
uh so at this point i don't think i have
the information to align it with
thank units for that and that's going to
be a helpful spreadsheet i think so
representative weiler oh thank you i've
heard this
ind waiver ind waiver a few times and
i've never
i didn't find it in the list of acronyms
what does it
stand for oh i will have to ask john to
add a to the list of acronyms henry do
you want to
yeah it's institutions of medical uh
mental disease that um the
feds as you know representative weiler
you know when someone's admitted to the
state hospital as an example that
they limit the amount that they pay in
the rest of that obligation
um rests with the state in general funds
what the imd waiver would allow is for
the state to be able to access
additional federal fund matching um for
care of people
who are admitted to different facilities
including the state hospital
thank you i guess i was looking it up
wrong because i thought i
ampersand d or i november d
but uh i didn't look at them but on imd
i kept hearing it as i nd
thank you mike delta yeah
indiana mike delta okay representative
do you have a follow-up sir
no i don't thank you representative
verve
thank you it's m i thought it was a
nancy that's not my question but
listen okay
um so my question is on that line 102
that you've been talking about contrast
for program services
is that all federal funds i believe it's
50 50 athena
questions at this point do you remember
okay so the next accounting unit is uh
79.39 which is
the state phase down or uh dual
eligibles
um that the state is required
to fund uh this is a hundred percent
there is a prioritized need around this
so what i would tell you
and henry could give you some background
on what the program is but
um one of the complicating factors of
this program
is that we find out in october of the
fiscal year that we are
in what the rate we're going to have to
pay is
and so there have been traditionally
rate uh
increases um so we
um we do have a prioritized need for
that
the reason that fiscal year 20 actuals
are so
low is because of the enhanced fmap they
process
the enhanced fmap on these expenditures
as a credit to us
so that is why it is 45 million and not
closer to the 48 that i believe it was
if kind of think about it in the
simplest terms it's
part d um subsidy for those
medicare beneficiaries who also qualify
for medicaid
dual eligible that is paying for their
prescription
uh drug benefit and um the
amount that the state has to be paid is
based on a
historical for each state
in terms of what their historical
spending on
pharmaceuticals have been based on a
trend factor
and as as karen said we've been
fortunate in this
period of time to get some enhanced fmap
to cover it but we
depending on how long that enhanced that
map is available in the time we did the
budget we
didn't know and we still don't know
exactly how long it's going to be
available that there would be
a shortage um over what was in the
governor's budget if it ended
so what what's your ballpark estimate of
how much this is going to be short do
you think what's what or what's our risk
variable here what
what might it be do you want to
grab that one yeah so roughly in 22
it's about 2 million and in 23 because
it's compounded
but i would say as i know that general
funds are certainly in demand
in this budget is that one thing that
could be very helpful
is to add a class note here to allow us
to carry the funds over from 22 to 23
where the public health emergency is
likely to go until at least december
i think that this 48 million might be
okay
to get us through 22 and potentially
even be
some funds left that we could carry into
23 and then have enough funds in 23.
so unless you have a class note you
can't do that
you can't just correct
if there's no question it it uh
it lapses at the end of the year
so mr ripple can you add that as
something that we would ought to
thank you representative walner you have
your hand up
um yes i just wondered how many um
people are in this would
be dual eligible how many clients do we
have in this area
a little over 19 000 give you the
number if i just look it up for a moment
[Music]
here
2016.
is has it been has it been going up did
you see an increase in this area during
an endemic
yes some slight increase
it's about a thousand up i think or
roughly that or so
so a thousand on nineteen thousand
okay thank you
so moving down to uh 7943
this is the uncompensated care fund
otherwise known as
dish so there are no general funds in
this account
the uh the private local funds coming in
here
is the medicaid enhancement tax that we
receive from the department of revenue
administration
and the federal funds is of course
medicaid
the reason you see a higher uh federal
match
here in fiscal year 20 is because of the
enhanced staff map
and athena correct me if i'm wrong oh no
never mind
is it yep no
is there a typo on the federal funds in
no there isn't sorry i missed that it
was 119 million
118 to 119. uh the audit
fund set aside class 41 and this is true
throughout the entire department never
has any general funds in them
so that's a very weird match right i
mean that's almost like 49
to 51 or even smaller so if you took out
the 118 980 here
um then it would be 50 50. the 118 980
is is 100
federal
all right representative walner you have
a question followed by representative
weiler
uh wyler private local funds where do
they come from
that's the medicaid enhancement tax that
comes from the department of revenue
administration
thank you you're welcome t as we call
matt yes met matt
how do i'm just curious how you estimate
this
on what basis are you estimating what
the uncompensated care fund needs to be
here
or wants to be so it's really based on
the medicaid enhancement tax and and
what the anticipated medicaid
enhancement tax is
because met is administered by dra they
are primarily responsible for coming up
with
revenue estimates for met we do assist
them to give them a sense of
what the current
market if you will of the hospitals
looks like what the
you know how the current revenues might
be affected et cetera et cetera
um but that is where that number comes
from
so with the extra people on medicaid
because they were protected during the
pandemic from losing eligibility
i i would just is is that why
we went from like 128 million and 20 to
123 to 119
so the higher federal funds in fiscal
year 20 is because of the enhanced fmap
so that was probably actually budgeted
somewhere closer to that 123 number
um so the reduction that you're seeing
from 21 to 22 is really related to the
pandemic the
the tax is set uh the tax is paid
on the previous calendar year of when
they pay
so in fiscal year 22 they will be paying
the tax
on net patient no yeah patient service
revenue
i did audit the medicaid enhancement tax
when i worked for dra but my knowledge
is starting to fade
um so that would be based on
calendar year 21 which we all know has
had some
uh representative while are your hand is
up sir
hello you have a question
no okay uh go ahead and you can continue
okay so moving along uh
to accounting unit 7945 is ehr
and i would dean henry or athena to
remind me what this accounting unit
is this goes back a ways karen um
this was a incentive that i think was in
came out in 2008 or 2010 for
healthcare providers to adopt electronic
medical records
it was financed at the fed level on a 90
basis 90 fed 10 state the program
is ending what you're seeing is that the
costs that we're carrying in 22 and 23
are
largely related to the administration of
the auditing and the final
the final claims by the by the health
care providers
medicare medicare ran a similar program
basically
so do we have good data from this
payment program so that we know uh
the extent to which the ehr has been
implemented
in new hampshire and where we still have
people
who are not on ehrs like loan providers
to
is there good do we have good data
because we had this program
we would have good data on on those that
participate in the program we wouldn't
necessarily have
a full insight into those who didn't
ever apply for it
but i think we could probably from the
data that we do have
make some good educated assessments of
where the gaps might been
sometime in months from now i i'd be
curious
about our ehr penetration rate and where
we're still
uh lacking uh providers who
but that's that's not for this budget
drill sure
okay are there any questions here
all right i'm not seeing any we can go
okay moving along to 7948
this is uh our the department's uh
largest accounting unit this is medicaid
care management
this is standard medicaid the private
local funds in this accounting unit
are the remainder of the medicaid
enhancement tax that is not in
the dish account you will also note here
that classline 535
and 563 are the two accounting units
from dcy are two class lines i'm sorry
from dcyf and those are dcyf
expenditures that are medicaid
expenditures
and that is a vast majority of
the increase in this accounting unit
okay so there are no personnel here
because they're all over on that
medicaid administration line
correct
uh representative walner has a question
yes this this would be where in
20 and 21 we would see the three and a
half percent um
rate increase for providers is that
correct the three point one percent rate
increase yes
okay and so that is not care
well we carried it i mean we didn't take
it away from them but
there's no new rate increase in the next
in the next budget i believe that's what
henry testified to yes
so do you could you tell me
how long had medicaid providers
gone without a rate increase
before last but before the biennium
we're in now
representative wallner thank you for the
question um i think there'd be a variety
of
answers like for example um hospitals
um where i'm a bit familiar with it been
you know
decades since their last increase
for um physicians uh somewhat similar
but it ranged from a few years to you
know
a couple of decades potentially in some
instances
like home health was another one that i
think had some increases along the way
but we could give you something more
specific on that
and that rate increase is strictly a
federal decision no that was a
legislative decision in 2019 to provide
two 3.1 percent increases and
so so the decision not to increase
the reimbursement rate has has been
a state legislature decision
yes all right representative waller your
hand is up do you have a follow-up
yes i do um so
could you speak for a minute as i mean i
know we had gone
for many many years in a number of areas
can you speak for
just a minute about what the
ramifications of that were were there
providers who actually did not accept
medicaid
what what happened what what were some
of the outcomes
of not having a keeping pace with
cost of living costs of medical care for
our providers
so so i think it come at it from two
different angles one was
um sort of access issues we
were able to if you will satisfy
access i think what the strong pressure
that we got from providers
on a legislative level i think in 2018
and 19
is a function of that in terms of the
cross subsidies that
meaning you know what you can collect
from commercial insurance what you can
collect from medicare that that the
ability to cross-subsidize medicaid was
was not uh able to be handled anymore by
many
provider types and they needed a level
of increase i think that
i would note that for example in the the
dish program for hospitals that there is
some compensation for uncompensated uh
care
and that's outside of the rate increases
if you will
that continue to evolve again not
necessarily keeping up with the full
cost of uncompensated care
and then nursing the county nursing
facilities receiving
supplemental payments in terms of the
[Music]
m quip medicaid quality incentive
payment and pro share that
that helped to defray some of the the
cost but i think it just became
you know fairly universal um that
you know the ability to support uh
medicaid's
standalone and maintain a level of
medicaid patients within a particular
practice that
i think the pressure was being felt
there and i think the legislature also
acted
in 2018 i believe it was to improve
mental health rates um which
was carried forward into 19 and 20 and
21 there was
investment there and sud rates um
those are two rates that you know where
there was significant pressures
um that worked that did have some
intermediate uh help on but i think even
there
that you know continuing to sustain that
and then
the transition when um if you remember
medicaid expansion
was originally on the exchange and so
that the reimbursement rates for the
expansion population at one point were
allowed to be higher
um and then the federal government and
then the transition
for the state to move back the expansion
population into the standard program
represented a rate cut and savings to
the state as well
so i think all those things combined
together led to
you know the provider community saying
we need some relief here
more than what has been able to been
for the question yes
so mr littman when
when providers um
can't keep up through when medicaid does
not keep up with
the cost to the provider the provider
do you think that that then gets pushed
back into the private market
and um the private insurance
ends up being higher because medicaid
has um
been underfunded i think in part
it does but also in part i think the
the adjustments to the to the dish
program for example
um were intended to help offset that
um and you know the fact that that uh
you know today or at the time there's 50
000 now 70 000 people who had no
insurance
um now have some level of coverage that
those things taken together i think
we're intended to
help provide some relief there um albeit
maybe not 100
relief thank you
uh so so leveraging off of what
representative walner just said i think
you made an offer mr lippman
to give us a a history of the rate
increases
or lack thereof um i i would like to see
that
and it sounded like sometimes the rate
increases were bifurcated towards
particular clinical areas
if you could make that distinction if
there is one i'd
i'd like to see that i think that um
we should be able to look to athena here
i think we have
records of different
if i can go back maybe a decade or
something like that 10 years that might
make it
a quicker turnaround than having to go
back 20 or 30 years
i'm not looking for the hard stuff to do
but if you can do a decade pretty easily
that's relevant
okay um representative earth your hands
up
thank you could you remind me what line
was the dcyf included in is that five
three five
five three five and five six three both
of them okay
are there any other questions in this
area
so i guess i have the same a similar
question
how on what just on what basis
are we coming up with an estimate
for say the federal funds on uh
zero zero zero for uh medicaid
care management i could take that one
karen
sure so i think the underlying the
medicaid care management program is that
the state
uses an actuarial firm to develop
the expenditures and that the federal
government has certain standards with
respect to
historical periods that you have to use
and so the medicaid
if you will expenditures to the managed
care program
receive quite a bit of work in their
development
um looking at various spending patents
for example pharmacy is like 18 to 20
percent of the
spend in the managed care program we
have uh
the actuarial firm has experts in the
pharmacy
area the to help look at what's being
spent we have a formulary that's
reviewed but basically
we have to meet a certain federal
standard in order to
and it has to be approved by federal
actuaries as well
um before we can get a rate adopted and
that's the basis in which we can draw a
federal match
that federal match is then driven off of
the
beneficiaries type so for example for
the expansion it would be 90
federal for um a chip for
the higher uh reimbursement chip group
it's
going to be 64. 5
in the next biennium here and for the
standard population it's 50
um and so basically the the derivative
of the federal match is based on what
the actuarial expected spend pictures
are for the population and each of those
populations are studied separately
so we could we so that we do have some
levers still of controlling our spend by
things like
making an eligibility decision around uh
healthy people or
work people with the ability to go get a
job
putting them on medicaid eligibility or
or if we came up with a silver bullet
and found a way to get our pharmacy
costs down
those are things that we could do that
would the actuaries would factor in
yes as well like for example pharmacy is
a good one where we um one of the
one of the things that you'll find if
you do some research on where can
medicaid programs affect their spend is
you know
moving it to a statewide pdl um
pharmacy drug list it helps the
it helps the state enhance its rebate
position and also makes it easier on
providers to
prescribe because there's more
consistency but other things that we we
talked about
earlier the idn as an example different
care management intervention someone
who's
was using the er 30 times a year who's
now using it twice a year
um you know if you look at different
areas of utilization that
our biggest opportunity in
in managing the program aside from the
number of people
enrolled in the type of people who are
enrolled is by
uh managing it so that there's a the
appropriate utilization
the right care the right time the right
place that's that's where
the from a transformation effort
standpoint i think the department
is trying to strengthen both what it
does and what the provider community
does
in terms of trying to um to if you will
right
position the care that's delivered
that's our our biggest opportunity
you know the when you look at the
administrative spend versus the
the medical spend you know 89 of the
of the dollars here are going towards
paying providers for the services that
they use
and trying to make sure that those
services are appropriate
um and um you know needed
are are what's a big part of what the
managed care
organizations do as well as the
department
and then on top of that is the program
integrity activities to make sure that
you know the department is not
experiencing fraud waste or abuse great
great answer thank you uh what other
questions are there in this area
i'm not seeing any so you can continue
all right great
the next accounting unit is 70 51
which is the child health insurance
program which henry has
uh spoke about extensively um
this accounting unit is fairly new i
believe it was new in the 2021 biennium
uh it used to be that these expenditures
were included within 79.48 um
and because that accounting unit um had
become so large and due to an audit
finding from kpmg we now do
and athena correct me if i'm wrong but
the agents the new agency income there
is that no i'm going to ask you what it
so the increase in
or the addition of the agency income are
the drug rebates that are related to
the chip population previously in 2021
we had budgeted those rebates in 79.48
but i do want to mention the increase or
rather the decrease in the federal funds
over the years
in fed fiscal year 18 and 19 that
federal match was 88
in fed fiscal year 20 it was reduced to
76.5
although again in 20 and 21 we're seeing
the increased fmap here as well
in fed fiscal year 21 that standard chip
match goes down to 65
55 so i
my math is wrong because looking at fy
the 73 million versus the 37 million
that doesn't look like a 55
match 65
65 federal but we also added some
i'm sure your math is right but it still
doesn't look like we're coming up with
our 45 percent
it's 35 35 35
general
minus the drug we do here you say the
federal match was
five five or six five six five
oh that's the problem right there my my
hearing
okay uh representative earth do you have
a question
i just couldn't hear the word the one
with rebates
the agency income here is drug rebates
drug rebates thank you
you're welcome drug or vaccine
you have a follow-up representative now
representative weiler
uh thank you i missed hearing the number
i believe henry's looking it up yeah i'm
looking it up too
so the the children um
the low-income children uh
seven 76 ninety and the the
uh chip the enhanced match chip children
are 17
312.
what's the 17 000 the one where we um
have the eligibility from 196 to 323
of poverty that's that's where we get an
enhanced match
i'm sorry i didn't hear your full
question representative no i mean who
decided to go to that
increased way up to 300 percent of
poverty was that something we put in we
put in the budget or was it something
the feds told us
no i think it was something that the
state elected to do um
probably in the 90s available
300 percent seems it seems pretty
generous
i think it's again i think nationally it
averages 255.
i think that the idea is
i think from a policy standpoint has
been that covering children and making
sure they get their
their well child care and to phrase
costs and
other areas of your budget later on um
and like dcyf and
other extended medical costs and i think
that that was the the basis uh that it
was adopted
family of four off the top of your head
what's 300 percent of bothering
the uh so roughly about
four i think it's around 16 000 as
poverty right is four times sixteen
would be about
sixty four thousand well
if you understand like a family
commercial four usually it was about
twenty some thousand
i think for i'll have to i don't have it
i guess off the top of my head i
know for a single person at 16 that's
what i was using as the
multiplier um but you know if you look
at what a policy cost for a family plan
it's
in the commercial market it's uh it's
well over 20 000
um and and so if you think about what
the
the target for someone spending in the
on the um
exchanges is you know somewhere between
two and eight eight and a half percent
of income that's
a lot of children may not otherwise get
covered as i think why that they go up
to that level
insurance companies got an awful greedy
i mean everyone is seeing it for
themselves it's just a huge
impact uh on on the general fund
going from 17 million and 20
to projected to go to 37 million and
23.
it's just that's just a very large
increase so so what
if we were to project this out another
budget
term or two is is is this growth rate
this growth rate is not going to
continue is it
no the increase between 22 and 23 is
that group of chip kids that you were
just speaking about
they were previously budgeted in 79 48
but again because they're eligible for
the same enhanced
chip f map we budgeted them in the chip
a lot of what's got my attention is an
accounting transfer
yes yes yeah
i'm not seeing any
the next accounting unit is eight zero
zero nine which is medicaid management
information system
or mmis uh i believe henry spoke
extensively about this this area does
have a
part of what you're seeing here is the
the part of the increase is because of
implementation
of the modular mmis that dave weeder
spoke about earlier
where you do have to run two systems
simultaneously
for a period of time and so then you're
sort of paying a little bit more for a
period of time until you make that full
transition
so that's why the expenditures are a
little higher here
um i do anticipate at you know as the
project fully implements that we'll see
these expenditures
uh representative norgren
hi good afternoon um could we
could you indulge me to go back to 57
7 51. um
could we have a history of the
increases and also
uh acknowledge what income rates those
would be
can we go back a few budgets
i'm sorry are you speaking about 70 51
yes
i think as henry spoke about it the the
300 goes back to the
90s but we'll we can certainly get that
information
well and i think the income levels would
be helpful too
okay so i think we're back to
uh mmis
and in fy21
we're at three million and i understand
we've had a lot of vacancies
and a lot of borrowed manpower
and we're going to jump to 12 million
in fy 22 and i heard you say we're going
to run redundant systems for a while
until we can cut over and go live fully
on the new system
so um what i would mention is fiscal
year 21 here was substantially
underfunded
uh it was not funded in in the phases of
the budget as you can see
the fiscal year 20 is is much higher um
general funds are much higher so we've
actually needed to transfer funds
into there if we haven't done it already
we're going to before the fiscal year
ends um so i would mention that about
fiscal year 21.
i think we needed 13 million to
to complete uh additional funds to
complete 21
that we had to find and um but the new
contract anticipates that we
will be funding um you know some of the
what karen was talking about which i
think is about 12 million of it
so this number will land somewhere
around 33 to 35 million
okay all right well sometime after march
25th i i would love to have a deep dive
into this project
um and i don't know if it has to be a
whole division three thing
but i would like to see see this project
closer because i think what's going to
happen is the senate will take our
budget and they're going to come back
and so i have some time to get smarter
here there's a lot of money and a lot of
benefit from doing this and i'm just
i just would like to see it if uh if we
could
we had done a presentation for the
government council a business
presentation
um this last week and um so we'll be
working on this because we have to bring
a contract forward
before the end of the state fiscal year
so
we'll be putting together information
all right
well thank you and certainly i don't
all right uh are there any other
i'm not seeing any are we done was that
it
uh no one last one is medicaid to
schools which is 100 federal
which i believe you you talked a little
bit about in
um chris antonello's presentation uh
so this concept of medicaid to schools
are i i think i saw chris on earlier
um are we are we
actively working through the doe so that
as they as they add uh like like in our
local auburn village school
we we added additional renovation space
and we added
uh like an occupational therapist area
in a physical therapist area
and as i was looking at the the clinical
staff that was going in there i was
thinking
you know we're really close to having a
full-on
clinic in here can we can we really
start
building medicaid uh for this clinic
operation we're running inside the
schools
is that really what this is for
medicaid eligible students where
services are provided in the school
yes that is what this is intended for um
and i mentioned earlier the senate bill
from from last session um
[Music]
that the you know telemedicine is
available to the schools at basically
any
service that a qualified treatment
provider meaning someone who is
duly licensed by their appropriate
professional board and it's a covered
service under medicaid
that schools can build the medicaid
program for and but what
schools have to pay is they they
contribute 50 percent of
the cost in other words they do what is
called a certified public expenditure
um and so when they build the state um
half of it is covered they get half
their money that what they would
otherwise do because they're responsible
under the just like we have to do in
other parts of the medicaid program
cover cover a minimum of 50 match
except when there is this enhanced
fmap situation the schools would only be
responsible for
43.8 percent of the the cost and they
could get reimbursement of the
56.2 percent and what ended up happening
is there was
in between uh 20 and 21 as
20 we had to recalibrate the program for
um
you know new guidance or clarification
of guidance
and the work with the legislature on
some things in the office of
professional licensure
on others so that in the long run
schools will be able to do this
we are working very close with the
department of education on this
we participate in a couple different
there's a the new hampshire charitable
foundation has
put together a work group of both
department of education
medicaid as well as other stakeholders
like school districts
to to work together and most recently
approved a grant
to help develop a cooperative to support
schools so that they can take further
advantage of the
medicaid schools program what's our
penetration rate
what what percentage of schools in new
hampshire do you think
are leveraging this program to some
degree
there i think there are 172 school
districts i think there are only
approximately nine that don't
participate in it at all
this was my argument at hb in the
division
two was that we were never able to find
out when it's
when a district says we spent three and
a half times
the average cost per student
special education funds and you didn't
know whether that three and a half times
was coming from medicaid for schools or
where it was coming from and they
wouldn't tell you
they always hid behind hipaa
so i think we ought to have something in
hb2
to say that you can't count that money
okay did you get
did you get a note on that mr ripple do
you have any follow-up questions of
representative weiler to make sure you
understand what he's
uh asking for yeah that one i didn't
quite catch representatives
when we were in uh division two and
we're talking about
when a district decides to go to the
catastrophic aid
to spend three and a half times the
normal cost of a student
and then they can ask for catastrophic
aid and they get 80
of their costs up until they spend 10
times the average cost at which time
catastrophic care takes over 100
so if they were getting money from other
sources
like medicaid to schools they would
still count that
in the three and a half times and if you
if you said
are you counting any other monies other
than your own district funds
they didn't have to tell you when they
wouldn't
okay kevin if i could
what the schools can collect under
medicaid to schools is
50 of uh generally 50 percent of the
medicaid fee schedule
and during the the
enhanced fmap it's 56.2 percent of the
i'm not seeing any other hands
representative weiler did you have a
follow-up
no thanks okay all right
so so now i think we're done is that
right that is correct
we are done with the accounting units
that's getting us very close to being in
overall
uh representative earth do you have a
question i wasn't able to
ask karen about three accounting units
just to know if they
were existing in fy 21.
okay i will do my best go ahead um
what area was that in bureau family
assistance
and then we don't have any expenditures
in there for 22 and 23.
no no no and uh you don't have it in
there for um 21. sorry
i think the new accounting unit i think
that got moved from dcyf
okay and then 7215 ssbg
also in that same bureau family
assistance i think that's the same thing
but i'd have to double check
and then 7216 a kinship grant
that one did come from dcyf okay we say
came from as new
as new entities as in it was previously
budgeted in dcyf and we moved it to dehs
i think joe ripsom talked about it in
his budget presentation
i guess what i'm saying is what would i
would it just be a subpart of one of
those or would it be a separate
standalone thing would i be able to find
sspg and dcyf
i don't remember if they were standalone
accounting units in dcyf or not
i i'd have to get that for you okay
thank you
you're more likely just absorbed in a
different program
i would guess probably that i i'm not
okay uh so um
mr lippman you you've talked a lot do
you have any sort of uh
summary thoughts for us after we've gone
through all of this and
because we've we're freshly broken
through all the brush do you have a big
picture of you first
as we summarize i guess the big picture
with respect to
what is going to be available from a
federal matching
perspective based on the length of the
public health emergency
is something that we will have to
continue to evolve as we move through
the phases here um and i think that some
of the priority needs
that were identified could be affected
by that
as well for example the we talked about
the state phase down
um in terms of from an operational
standpoint filling in
some of these vacant positions are
really important if
we can't move um forward on i.t
projects without staff um and uh
that it's important to do so so that we
don't lose federal match
um in that area um and
you know in terms of the things like
dental i think that um you'll your you
and your colleagues will i think be
judging the
um what's in the two bills that are
moving through the senate in the house
they think that
you can't disconnect the mouth from the
rest of the body that there are
long-term um while there's some
short-term costs or long-term
benefits i think of as you've pointed
out representative edwards in terms of
not ignoring those types of situations
i think that you know we run
a pretty lean and efficient program
overall there are opportunities to
improve and
i think we disclose some of those in our
quality presentation that we're going to
continue to work on
and we appreciate the support that you
can
provide to the beneficiaries that we
serve
in this uh this budget um i don't know
if
athena or karen you would add anything
to that
[Music]
i think so other than just saying thank
45 attendees and we're going to give it
a few seconds
for somebody to see if they want to
raise their hand and make a comment for
the
the good of the committee so we learn
something more about the budget
give it a second i'm not seeing any
hands going up
all right uh mr ripple i'm getting ready
to adjourn
what have i forgotten i think you have
one more
set of presentations left right karen
yes long term supports and services
oh is that today yeah so we shouldn't
adjourn
all right let's go i thought we were
done i'm sorry
okay let's take a let's schedule for
tomorrow
schedule for tomorrow
uh we we don't meet tomorrow
we've everyone's got town meeting day
tomorrow so i i don't think we have
anything in the house calendar
mr ripple what what are you going to say
can we meet tomorrow afternoon
you do actually that was last week it
was decided that you would meet tomorrow
starting at noon so you do have some
time set aside tomorrow and it's not for
anything
specific at this point so if you wanted
to continue with this presentation
tomorrow instead you could do that
i would say that this presentation
or just gonna say i would say that this
presentation probably will take at least
three to four hours so i don't know if
you want to start it today
are you are you available to support it
tomorrow afternoon
i am with you however many days and
hours you need me
i mean the the department head i don't
know who's yes
yes i did speak with deb sheets as well
and she is
available whenever you need her to be
available so she can be available
tomorrow as well
so i guess i didn't look at the calendar
very well what time do we start noon
so um is this technically an adjournment
for the day or a resource
recess till tomorrow you could adjourn
for the day
so um i'm not seeing anyone suggesting
that we shouldn't adjourn
let's go ahead and adjourn this meeting